e
all right it's
9:30 um so I'd like to open up the work
session on uh s SP
371 um and there's a proposed Chang so
um I'll introduce the content to the
subcommittee and then we can discuss it
um last time we met on 371 there wasn't
a great deal of opposition from the
subcommittee to the underlying content
of the bill basically um resident
doctors um were looking for uh or well
actually the administration I would say
more Dartmouth was looking for an
exception to the twoe filing period for
renewal of license um because they do it
on behalf of the resident doctors
because obviously the resident doctors
are working like 80 hours a week so
which is completely reasonable um so we
didn't really have any problem with the
the content of the underlying Bill uh
since that time I have uh had some
further discussion I've gained some more
information um and so my my personal
position on the bill has changed um so
and I'll give you my reasons why uh in
order to Grant an exception in my
opinion from the 2-year licensing
requirement um we'd have to really prove
some sort of substantial hardship sh
that was being caused to Dartmouth um
because really it's a bill for Dartmouth
um either from a monetary perspective or
from a Time perspective it was either
going to be really overburdening for
them from a time commitment or um it was
going to cost them a lot more money and
in either case I was willing to make the
exception to the rule um on the money
piece I learned that the fee is $50 to
renew the license because the point of
Licensing for each for each for each
individual
um because the point of lure is not to
make money they're not trying to turn
profit on it if they have to do it more
frequently they'll just reduce the
license fee so if they have to
renew you know one extra time instead of
it being 50 for the full term it'll just
be 25 for the two times that they have
to file so there's no financial hardship
that's going to be incurred by the
hospital for this for this to happen um
I also learned that oplc will not and
has not well has not I mean if we tell
them they have to then they will but um
has not ever gone more than four years
on a license so the maximum number of
renewals that are going to happen in
this situation are one at the 2-year
Mark with uh 450 of approximately 450
resident physicians at Dartmouth I'm
assuming staggered that's an average of
just over a 100 people who are going to
be looking for renewal on on an annual
basis is what basically what they're
going to have to come up with so the
last question that for me I thought
needed to be answered was whether a Time
hardship was going to be created by the
number of things that they were going to
have to do so I looked into the process
I can share it with the subcommittee um
I don't know if you guys have ever had
to deal with license renewal in the
state I do for food service license so
I'm familiar with the process that
director Courtney was sharing with me
where on your initial license
application you'll fill out all of your
information you'll submit it to the
department when you get your
renewal basically all of the information
is filled out for you you just have to
verify that nothing has
changed say nothing has changed if
nothing has changed and then in I'm not
sure exactly how oplc will do it but in
my case I don't have to respond if
nothing has changed I just send in my
renewal fee and I'm done so if it takes
5 minutes per application renewal which
looking at the application renewal in my
opinion I don't think it would take
really much more than that if that uh
depending on how oplc you know
fine-tunes that application process um
it's about an 8h hour workday for one
person once a year and to Grant an
talking one one oplc staff no one person
at Dartmouth filling out the renewal
applications about a day's worth of work
year and and as soon as you start
granting exceptions to the rules then
everybody's going to want an exception
for this reason or that reason so I mean
I'm fine I was fine and I'm I still am
fine if there was if I felt like there
was truly a hardship that was going to
be put on Dartmouth we don't need to do
that I don't think anybody has a desire
to do that um you know but that's got to
be balanced by being even-handed across
the board as well so I personally after
looking into it a lot more uh closely
could not find the financial hardship
because they're just going to reduce the
fee so that they're basically spending
the same amount of money and when I was
looking for the time hardship in the end
I couldn't find that either so so that's
kind of where I landed on the underlying
Bill and I'm more than happy to open it
up to the subcommittee for yeah commun
conversation go ahead
Peter thanks Mr chair so the thing is um
the this is going to be done by mail or
is it potentially going to be done
electronically no it's going to be done
electronically yeah so in other words it
it'll come up on the computer or the
cell phone of the the in individual
resident doctor that's affected he or
she will put potentially push the button
um on their cell phone or on their
computer or whatever and and if if
there's any change he or she will make
that change if not they'll just no
change and they're good so um it
probably won't be the resident physician
uh it'll be an administrator at
Dartmouth Hitchcock even better yes but
the way the way that it works the way
that I've engaged with the system and it
sounds like to the director this is what
they're heading towards you will receive
a paper in the mail uh that says here's
the information that we have on file has
anything changed now being a residency
more than likely nothing will have
changed um and what they do in my case
is they simply say if there are no
changes to be made to the application
don't respond we'll just assume that
it's here and if we receive your filing
fee we're then you'll be renewed for
another another year that's how it
happens in the food service industry
anyway and it sounds like this process
will be the same so yes but it will be
online so if you do have to make changes
you can you know go into the portal and
if you're doing a 100 of these obviously
you get into a rhythm exactly the
staffer will be doing it at least that's
what they're saying they could always
push it off to the resident physician if
they want to that's their choice they're
doing it because they're helping their
physician out which I appreciate because
those people are working extraordinarily
hard um so yeah so it would be a system
like that so once again where you know
maybe a hundred of these 120 of these in
in a year um you know if it's for the
vast majority of them if it's just the
time it takes to write a check and send
it in the mail to ol uh to um
oplc um I just I can't find the hardship
in that to Grant the exception
personally
Steve yeah yeah it's I just couldn't
find the burden and once again if I
could if I could find the burden I would
I would do it you know like I'm not
trying to cause them any problems yeah I
absolutely give me one second I'll um
any other comments from the committee
love to hear from the public if you guys
want to testify come right up to the mic
on good morning morning morning thank
you very much uh representative Simon
and members of the committee recognize
that it's a work session so we
appreciate the opportunity to speak to
it we're here to speak to the bill and
please do because we're still talking
about the bill so yeah great um so for
the record my name is Matthew Hood I'm
the vice president of government
relations at Dartmouth Health you're
probably used to seeing my colleague
Courtney Tanner who's out of state uh
today and with me is Chelsea Nolan who's
the administrator of The Residency
program uh director excuse me uh of The
Residency program so has has insight
into the actual nuts and bolts of the
operation of this program and what
the failure to implement a variance or
uh uh for lack of a better word would
entail for Dartmouth Health excellent
thank you for being
here so to some of the points that you
made thank you for looking into the
process thoroughly and from speaking it
from your experience with regards to the
food um
industry what we have heard from the
oplc during this process of change is
that there would be yes the move to an
electronic can you hear me okay oh yeah
to an electronic system but as yet not
in place currently what we have is a
paper renewal process that does not
follow the process that you have
identified thus far if it is going to
move in that direction we have not heard
about that from the oplc uh there's
requirement to create a new application
from scratch with none of the
information that has been um con pre
previously obtained um as well there's
requirement that the program director
for that particular resident or fellow
uh complete a uh signatory saying that
they are still in good standing within
their training program so we have to
obtain both that from the program
director as well as the application as
well as a $50 check and I I will make a
little bit of a joke here but it's true
residents don't know what checks are um
we honestly now I believe you 100% they
they don't they don't understand checks
and they don't understand how they get a
copy of avoided check um to be get to be
able to get a reimbursement so we will
be very hopeful that the oplc when
moving to the process of having an
electronic system will allow for credit
card or a um to be able to allow them to
pay that in a timely fashion that has
been a holdup for us over the last
number of years including this year with
renewals being done because literally
they've never seen one before um so so
just for clarification the resident is
paying the renewal fee not the hospital
the resident pays the renewal fee
because the opl will not on the board
before it would not have allowed uh dhmc
to pay for all of the licenses that were
necessary and instead of check cutting
One Singular check for each of the 120
to 140 people per year that needed to be
renewed they'd required to have a
singular check go with each application
um connected to it so that they could
you know do their processing um then the
resident provides us with a um voided
check or something from their Bank
showing that it was paid and then our
accounts payable office will reimburse
them for that fee MH uh to the point
about the cost um you're right that if
we stayed at the original level of $50
per renewal it would be approximately
$9,000 a year that dhm would G dhmc
would pay which is not a significant
amount of money and yet we'd rather not
pay that money if we don't have to I
don't want you to either and put it
towards education and and other things
like that uh at least in the gme realm
that's what we're most most concerned
with uh we have not heard the idea that
they would maybe decrease the fee to $25
or to some lesser amount what we would
be of course very thankful for them to
be able to do
that um so just for your peace of mind
I've talked to the director about it
specifically and I will I mean she was
already in the space where they would do
that but I will insist that they do that
so great shouldn't create a a larger
financial burden for you or the doctors
understand the other piece around what
the administrative burden would be would
be with regards to your calculation of
approximately one day per year that be
necessary for an administrator to do
this work there's a variety of
confounding factors that go along with
that which where I would disagree with
you as to the amount of time um one of
those things has to do with the number
of Visa holders that we have at our
organization who need ecfmg status and
other kinds of requirements in terms of
upkeep of their visa to allow them to
continue to work at
dhmc so we have uh very specific
regulations we need to follow with
regards to those processes and the
licensing that takes place so that is a
more extensive process for Visa
holders in addition uh just for
clarification you only have to do that
if the license is being renewed you
don't have to do that on a regular basis
regardless at the renewal time we would
need to be providing that information to
the ecfmg to maintain their status as as
Visa holding uh resident trainees right
so I'm saying anytime we renewed okay so
if it's four years then you only have to
do that every four years if it's every
two years you're going to have to do
that every years exactly right and also
to your point um earlier
and I I don't know how much everyone
knows about what the training process
looks like for residents and fellows we
train people from 1 to 7 years depending
on the length of training so a
neurosurgeon gets seven years of
training and someone who is in a
preliminary year in in surgery gets one
and then goes on to four additional
years of training so we are looking at a
difference between renewing people every
four years which most people would get
done within that 4-year period of time
most residencies are 3 to 5 years long
um and instead moving it to two or three
times that we would need to renew people
Additionally the way that the board at
the oplc has put this forward to us is
that when a resident applies for their
license so right now people are applying
to start in June when they start with us
for our June orientation and July their
license will become effective let's say
if I send in my license and and the oplc
approves it on April 15th it will be
good for 2 years to April 15th of the
following year the previous way that
licenses were being were being done was
that they would all expire on June 30th
let's say of every every year or every
other year for people um so what we're
going to do is have this continual
update and tracking of all of the
individuals at the time that they are
actually receiving their license as
opposed to having a standard license
date so to your point of whether it
takes eight hours for someone to do that
work it would definitely take them
longer than that but it would also be
spread over a period of time in order to
meet all of the timing um CL need needs
and to get each of them through because
we definitely do have people who begin
about half of our residents and fellows
start in July half start in June and
then we have people who are off cycle as
well all of this is just to say that
there is some Nuance to the way in which
this is done in the Resident population
finally I would also note that they are
contracted to work at dhmc for the
entirety of their training if they
choose to leave because they want to
relocate to another place or they've
chosen to move to a different specialty
because they're not a competent
clinician in a particular way but they
could be in a different
um I lost my train of thought uh if they
leave they're going someplace else if
they if they have to do that
um oh sorry totally lost my train do
something with with the license renewal
or their license status would change
or um well while chesy uh grabs for that
thought the only where I went where I
thought she was going with that thought
is that yes residents obviously train at
the medical center but residents are
also placed throughout the state so at
conquered Hospital Portsmouth elsewhere
um at other locations so um our
residents truly training the workforce
for the state and and region not just
for the Lebanon Anover area I think that
the thing we're most concerned about
really is the opportunity to be able to
work directly with the oplc on a process
that works well for this this particular
group of individuals who are contracted
to work in one place who are not
required to provide CME like a like a
regular attending physician would be um
and who really if they leave our
employee at dhmc and move somewhere else
they no longer can have their training
license at all and so we're really tied
to them and they're really tied to us
with regards to these processes and
ensuring that they have their
appropriate lure in place at all times
because if were to have a laps we would
immediately move them out of clinical
work until they had that license renewed
that is a thing that I am particularly
concerned about with regards to the
resident being the responsible party
which is what the op oplc has told us in
the past is sort of different than what
you've spoken about today um they really
told us that we could no longer help in
that process um in any kind of real way
we could in the back background you know
obviously P provide reporting to
programs and to Residents to remind them
that their licenses due to expire and
they're going to need to re um have it
reapplied um but the actual fact of
needing to have them reapply every two
years there really isn't anything that
is going to change about them within
that period of time the difference
between a two-year or fouryear renewal
is to me to me I understand it from the
idea of having all lure across the state
wanting to be standard and yet at the
same time this is a group of apprentices
honestly who are contracted to work with
us and there is nothing that's changing
about their stat status during that
2-year period of time if it did when
when a resident leaves early our office
communicates with the oplc to say that
person is no longer no longer in our
employee and no longer can have a
license so the piece around two versus
four years to us feels arbitrary for
sure um well um let me ask you well
actually any questions from the
subcommittee before I ask a
question okay um I I understand that the
status isn't really going to change from
two to four years does that differ from
when they're a fully licensed physician
though because that's really not going
to change from 2 to four years I either
will it other than that's just when the
state is requiring that they renew their
license uh I would argue that as a fully
licensed physician who is under who does
not have to require supervision from any
other individual in order to do their
job there is risk there that they that
the um state is taking on with regards
to the licensure of that individual and
they do require the continuing education
that needs to be provided to ensure that
they are continuing with the um the
depth of inform depth of knowledge that
they need within their specialty in
order to continue to do their job so
there's a different level of risk that
the state is taking on with regards to a
full-time attending physician who can
leave the employee of any place they
want and move and work anywhere in New
Hampshire as opposed to a resident who
is under supervision from an attending
physician and who is contracted to work
directly at our organization great thank
you for the the clarification I
appreciate
that just checking in any questions you
good you're good um let me think for a
second so that I can make sure I cover
all my bases
um so you did mention um that OPC has
said to you that the resident Physicians
will be responsible for their own
licensure renewal yes um and well first
I wanted to clarify from a mathematical
perspective I was saying only one more
license renewal that you would have
otherwise had to do because oplc and you
can tell me if this has been different
from your experience said they never
renew for more than four year like for
four years previously that was correct
yes right so if it was going out seven
they still would have had to renew at 4
correct anybody four five six or one day
day over four would be required okay um
and also clarification from what I was
saying before I was uh the mathematics
of eight hours or a work day was just to
simplify obviously I didn't think that
they were all happening on one day and
it was just going to take one understand
one person um
but uh so that's falling on them to
renew their own licenses correct um
which previously before the changes that
we've been making in oplc was not the
case you were just able to do the whole
thing yourself correct there wasn't an
actual we could communicate with
directly with the oplc and provide a
letter that said these individuals are
continuing on in their training as they
had received previously to know the
start and end date of training as soon
as soon as the application went through
to say yes confirmed these people are
moving forward and they would extend
their license so was a very simple
process that fell in line directly with
the initial application and the length
of training you expect somebody to be in
based on the specialty in which they're
training okay and just one more
clarification and I think I'm good uh
you had mentioned because you have a lot
of um International people working for
you there was other paperwork that you
had to fill out during a renewal cycle
and that goes to who the ecfmg yes can
you um give me the words that go with
the letters I actually don't know okay
in my office who manages that knows it
all inside and out but I can get it for
you okay um yeah just uh and so that's
outside of the state lure protocol
that's that's totally separate that's
Federal that's Federal okay but they the
federal bases it off of the state
requirements it's not that there's a
federal license it's just that there's
requirements with regards to Visa
holders in terms of what they can and
can't do when they're in training in the
United States and so anytime there's a
change to anything that has to do with
them we have to contact the ecfmg to
make sure that they are aware of that
because they're looking at their visa
status when they go home to let's say
India for a two week vacation to see
their family and come back we have
people who get stuck in India trying to
come back home so there's there's
requirements around any Visa holder and
um how they can train where they can
train what their license looks like Etc
okay and your average time that you feel
like it takes out to do that for a
person just average I know it's going to
be more for some less for others but uh
I I I guess I'd give it an hour okay per
per thank you so much for coming in and
testifying appreciate that anything else
from you guys before we uh no I was just
going to say thank you for the
opportunity to speak to the subcommittee
appreciate that realize you don't have
to do that and then with respect to the
hearing you're going to hear the similar
information I assume um but presume that
that's the information you're looking
for to inform the yes absolutely and you
know I'll I'll follow up with um
director Courtney they should be here
for uh we have a hearing at 10:15 or 10
10:15 um on an amendment for this bill
that has to do with the medical board um
so I can just check on some of the
concerns that you had in that time
period as well because we will be
executing this bill later today so I got
to make sure that I have all those ducks
in a row I'm sorry did you say you were
or were not going to be we will be
executing today on this bill so okay
thank you yep so I appreciate you coming
all
right represent boy any
thoughts okay um well I'm I'll
definitely follow up with director
Courtney and ver verify some stuff so
that when we talk about it later this
afternoon we have the information that
we need there
[Music]
um yeah I think um what I'd like to do
is look at the amendment briefly with
you guys so we know what that's about
going to committee um at the moment you
just want to leave it without
recommendation while we finish sorting
things out we can just discuss it with
the full committee I think
that's I'll make that motion without
recommendation do I have a second Peter
all in favor all right we'll go without
recommendation we'll talk about it with
the whole committee then um there's a an
amendment SB 371 uh we'll have a public
hearing on this in a little bit but I
just wanted the subcommittee to have a
bit of a heads up on it um we've been
restructuring the different boards uh in
oplc as we move responsibility from the
board to oplc for certain functions um
and so we hadn't done that with uh the
licensing and regulation of Physicians
and so most of this is language changing
um things moving things from the board
to the office like we've done with all
the other boards um there were a couple
of
things in here that
25 um we're and we may need to do a
floor amendment to this language here as
well to fix it but um we wanted to make
sure that even in these courtesy
licenses that can be given for 100 days
that the license that's held by the
individual uh is substantially similar
to the requirements that New Hampshire
has for their licensing which my
understanding is it's pretty much the
same across the board regardless um but
we want I just I felt more comfortable
having that
33 um we're just connecting the renewal
process to 3108 which is what we've been
talking about the every two years and um
all of the requirements that we have
that keep it consistent with everything
else but instead of delineating it in
its own language we're just tying it to
the what we've already put
statute
um just to keep it
simple and I suppose too so that if it
changes it will change with it we don't
thing I think those are the main
ones so once again we'll have a public
hearing on it so you guys can hear about
that but uh figured we'd get that work
done this year so that we don't have to
do it in some sort of subsequent year
since we're knee deep in it already
straightforward all right well we've got
a public heing in 4 minutes so I'll uh
adjourn the work
time
e
good
morning I'm opening the public hearing
on Senate Bill 302 and I call the
rosenal good morning thank you madam
chair members of the committee
for the record I'm Sydney
rosenal and I represent with the honor I
hope Senate District 13 in nashwa I'm
very pleased to bring you Senate Bill
302 which will make it easier for New
Hampshire patients to have teleah Health
appointments with their
Physicians who are located in another
state this issue was brought to me by a
constituent last year his wife is being
treated by a group of doctors in Boston
whom they like and know well my
constituent sometimes has interim telea
Health appointments on behalf of his
wife but because the doctors practice in
Massachusetts and don't have a New
Hampshire license my constituent has to
be physically located in Massachusetts
to talk with
them he sometimes is able to borrow a
room at a public library but the Wi-Fi
is not good and he often gets kicked out
sometimes he sits in a parking lot and
talks on the phone but he has to be
physically located in
Massachusetts this just doesn't make
sense to me
technology doesn't stop at the border
and I as I've spoken to people at
oplc the medical society and at the
Department of Justice and also last
spring I spoke with this chair of the
Board of
Medicine it became clear that a simple
very limited licensing exemption would
be helpful to New Hampshire
patients so this bill exempts an outof
State physician from needing a New
Hampshire medical
license only when they have an
established relationship with the
patient in the physician's home state of
Licensing and they see them in person at
least once a year but as often as the
patients's condition
requires this way people can have video
tella health or telephone appointments
with their doctors who practice
elsewhere from the comfort of home and
not have to drive over the state border
and sit in a parking lot I think it's a
common sense bill it's very
limited um it was very carefully crafted
to to be extremely narrow but I think it
will help a lot of New Hampshire
patients and I hope the committee will
find it a to pass thank you I'm happy to
take questions represent man
py thank you madam chair thank you
senator for taking my question um what
uh
this um going from the New Hampshire
Physicians dunella Health in Mass
Massachusetts or
Massachusetts Physicians doing tah
health for patients in New Hampshire is
there a
reciprocity like New
Hampshire uh Physicians seeing
Massachusetts patients just especially
in nashwa the Border across the street I
mean across the border and I have been
asked several times from the physicians
in New Hampshire they cannot
treat they can treat the patient when
they come to New Hampshire hospital or
their practice but TAA Health across the
border in perol L dunable is not allowed
so it's the similar situation have you
considered that with that yeah well in
that situation is particularly acute
across the river from Dartmouth hedgcock
where 40% of the patients live in
Vermont
unfortunately we cannot control how
other states license their Physicians
Massachusetts has not joined the
Physicians compact they've considered it
they haven't done it if they did it it
would make it easier but we are only
able to control what happens in in our
borders
so so we just can't do what you're
suggesting which a lot of Physicians
would like to see
happen follow up thank you madam chair
uh the followup to is from what I
understand the federal licensing for
Physicians New Hampshire doesn't belong
to
that and so uh New Hampshire you have to
get medical license in New Hampshire
whether you have in other states and
reciprocity is a cumbersome process is
would that make it easier just a
question that
I'm asking I I think you're referring to
the Physicians compact New Hampshire
doesn't I hope they will join it
yeah but if if if not this could apply
to somebody who has a procedure out at
the Mayo Clinic in
Minnesota wants to have a followup
appointment with the physician who did
the procedure this means they wouldn't
have to fly out to
Minnesota they could have a teleah
health appointment so this is this is a
small thing but I think it would be a
big thing
for
the comfort
and uh ease of New Hampshire's patients
without
jeopardizing health and
safety all right thank you other
questions thank you Senator thank you
good morning Madame chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Jessica esand I'm the senior public
policy manager for the Alzheimer's
Association here in New Hampshire uh I
am pleased to appear today in support of
Senate Bill 302 and thanks Senator Rosen
Wald and the sponsors for their
leadership on this issue um as you've
heard uh as we all know there is a
healthcare Workforce shortage in New
Hampshire for example affecting our
demographic in 2021 there were just 33
geriatricians in New Hampshire um
compared with the over 26,000 Granite
Staters living with Alzheimer's disease
this makes it really hard for folks to
receive Specialized Care in state and
has necessitated a lot of the folks that
we serve um to establish provider
relationships over state borders
oftentimes in
Massachusetts and as you've heard uh
accessing these appointments via tella
Health can be difficult this is causing
again as you heard folks to take uh
tella Health calls in parking lots over
the Border or look for a quiet place in
a library which is often unreliable and
not necessarily private uh so by making
this small exemption in law we really
feel that this would benefit and remove
what we see as an undue burden on not
only the folks that we work with uh who
have Alzheimer's or other dementia but
also their family members and caregivers
who are often um a part of the logistics
of getting them to these appointments
where they need to be and um are often
juggling other life responsibilities
employment Child Care Etc whatever they
may be so uh this small exemption would
allow these folks to access the
Specialized Care they need but from the
privacy and comfort of their own home um
and free up some time that could be
otherwise spent managing other other
responsibilities that they have so we
would ask that you uh support this
legislation and I'm happy to take any
questions
representative gold thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
and I apologize my mind was wandering a
little if you already addressed this but
my question is would this measure make
treatment more affordable for some
patients for example the um example we
got about having to fly to a far away
place where you've had treatment for
followup I mean I would think just
pragmatically you know the the cost
associated with travel whether it be gas
or mileage or airfare I I could see it
certainly cutting down on that in terms
of the the costs of treatment I wouldn't
be speaking to that but I do think it
would help defay Associated costs just
with
travel thank
you representative Schmidt thank you
madam chair uh I should have asked the
senator this question as well but
perhaps you can answer is there any
objection to this on the part of the
medical community or uh other
stakeholders
who would
be in some fashion harmed by this small
exemption which would clearly would be
beneficial for the patients and helpful
to the practitioners as well so is there
been any push back um I would defer to
the senator on that I have not had any
conversations indicating that but I
would no thank you thank you there's
also only speakers in support so
thank
you represent mudy thank you madam chair
quick question in terms of the P
Alzheimer's patients that you referred
to wouldn't this help them with the
transition of not leaving their comfort
zone where wherever they are because of
their state of mind and if they are in a
Alzheimer's care in
Massachusetts they can still get their
care from
the um or the vice versa if um they have
moved closer to the family in New
Hampshire but they were getting care in
Massachusetts by The Physicians they can
continue to get not having to
transition everything location Care and
Family Support yes I would very much
agree with that okay thank you all right
thank you for your testimony thank you
Carrie
[Music]
Dennis oh you you just turned that off
there you go thank you thank you um
thank you for having me my name is krie
Dennis I live in Auburn I have early
stage early onset Alzheimer's and I am
here to testify in support of Bill
302 when I began noticing problems with
my memory I brought my concerns up with
my primary care doctor he referred me
locally to have a cognitive test which I
passed it would be a he told me I was
fine it would be a conversation I would
have several times over that next year
during my final meeting with him
frustrated he told me that if I had
Alzheimer's I would have no idea that my
family would bring me in because I would
have no clue where I was
anger
aside this doctor did not have the
experience or the expertise to be able
to diagnose Alzheimer's especially early
onset
Alzheimer's
fortunately I am I worked for a company
that had the benefits of something
called an expert medical
opinion it recommended that I go to one
of the research hospitals in
Massachusetts I have been working with
Mass General Hospital for almost a year
and because the law requires me to be in
the same state as my doctor I have to be
in Massachusetts every time I speak with
him in one of my visits I had received a
test result over my
echart and uh I sent him a message and
he wanted to clarify and explain and
help me to understand what that
diagnosis meant and the fastest way to
do that was through a telec call um
unfortunately it meant that I had to
drive to a parking lot in Massachusetts
conversation driving to Boston is very
difficult for me my husband takes time
off from work with each visit I had
eight appointments last year three of
them could have easily been tah Health
appointments this diagnosis has been
hard and not getting to my doctors in
Massachusetts for the quality care that
I need is not going to get any easier
having access to meet with my doctor
that I trust and have a relationship
with is a huge benefit for me and my
husband um please support this bill and
thank you so much for taking the time to
hear
good morning Madam chair um my name is
Leah Farley and I live in hopkington New
Hampshire and I'm here to testify in
support of Senate Bill
302 um I've been diagnosed with young
younger onset Alzheimer's as well um due
to the shortage of neurologists and
other health care providers in New
Hampshire I get medical treatment at
Mass General Hospital memory care
because of the uh current constraint on
Physicians under the current law I'm
required to travel to Massachusetts for
every appointment even tell Health to
access care this is a burden to me as
well as my spouse who still works um I
had to close my business and we have
half the income now so his job's very
important um for insurance and um just
living so um in order for me to in order
to join me he has to take time off of
work um he he you know he could get
conference room and do it from work but
he has to take time off it's at least a
half day um every time we have a meeting
and um then we end up in a parking lot
or somewhere with poor Wi-Fi um
sometimes it's in and out um and uh it's
it's uncomfortable um but it's the best
that we can do right now um we'd like to
be spared this burden and um you know it
would be a big it would be one less
thing on our plate so you know having
the diagnosis is challenging um it would
be so helpful if accessing care was not
one of the
challenges um I respectfully ask that
you support this
Bill thank you for your
consideration representative Mani thank
you madam chair thank you for taking my
question um are you thank first of all
thank you for coming and sharing um
um your testimony with us are you
enrolled in any study that would
required to go or can be um accessed
through tele medicine because this is a
res Research Center and you have access
to uh new research and new methods of
treatment are you enrolled would that
help this bill would help help for you
to get engaged in those specialty
studies yes I'm not currently I was just
diagnosed in June last year um and it
rocked my world and uh I haven't I
hadn't gone any further I'm just now
through the Alzheimer's Association
getting the support and information I
need to know that there are hopeful
things I can do um and it would
definitely take away that barrier um I I
can't drive in Boston um everything I do
requires me to have somebody take me
there so thank you for thinking of that
yeah all right thank you thank you for
your testimony thank you Susan
elberger
oh you should have indicated you were a
rep I didn't uh didn't know on the
well told you sooner my apologies for
that uh thank you madam chair thank you
uh este deemed committee members for uh
allowing me to tell you about one of my
constituents and it's the couple who um
rep Senator Rosenwald mentioned at the
beginning I think all of us have uh
constituents who touch our hearts in
different ways when we go out
campaigning we say what are your
concerns and they say let me tell you a
story this is a story
Ry and Caroline which are not their
names have been married 48 years this
week Caroline was diagnosed with
Alzheimer's 15 years ago they were
planning to come themselves and
testify until uh Caroline had to be
admitted to a memory care unit in
February and Ry is meeting with the
doctor this morning so he asked me to
testify for him and said please tell my
story so I will
um prior to the pandemic there was no
problem with a phone call during when
Caroline was getting her care in
Massachusetts uh prior to the pandemic
there were no problems with phone calls
during the pandemic when tele medicine
became a major advantage uh for people
who couldn't travel that was fine and
then after the pandemic was over he was
told that he needed to drive to
Massachusetts with the spotty phone
reception the conversations in libraries
which are public places at the same time
he was a fulltime caregiver which meant
that he had to get respit care for his
wife so he could go and make a phone
call for her he did not want to have to
leave her but he did it was the only way
he could take care of her
care
uh she uh
a few months ago the reason that she is
now in a memory care unit is that when
they went to bed one night she was
afraid to go to bed with him because she
didn't know who he
was this is not a unique story this
happens to many of us as we get older
I'm the same age as they
are uh and I worry about this we owe it
to our constituents to not make their
lives
unnecessarily difficult so I encourage
you to support Senate Bill 302 to avoid
this kind of thing continuing to happen
thanks thank
that uh hi madam chair for the record
Matthew Hood uh vice president of
government
relations at Dartmouth Health my writing
was a little my writing was a little
quick so you might not doctor we we
understand that um no no no not a
physician uh government relations just
to be clear so uh I'll be very brief in
my
testimony as you've heard tellah Health
served an incredible role during the
pandemic and there was tremendous
flexibility across state lines um and
touth health as was noted
40% of the patient care that's provided
in the medical center in Lebanon is for
Vermont residents after the pandemic and
those flexibilities went away um we went
back to the the state that was discussed
uh which is you need to be the physician
uh in the state where the physician is
resident or the physician needs to be
licensed in other states we certainly
support expanded capacities via teleah
Health we would love reciprocity I want
to go on record is saying that would be
nice to have from the state of
Massachusetts uh in Vermont what they
have done is they are a compact state so
a physician could be licensed in
multiple states that are part of the
compact they also have tiers if you're
going to do tella Health under a certain
number of cases you got a certain lure
if you're going to do teleah Health on a
larger scale you get a different license
um or you could be fully licensed in
that state to treat all patients so I
just wanted to provide that information
uh certainly support the expansion of
coverage but would obviously love it if
our neighbors to the South uh were
similarly inclined is Vermont a compact
state yes okay good and for your
information during the pandemic we New
Hampshire issued tens of thousands of
physician licenses Pro I think to
everybody in Massachusetts Vermont or
main that asked so they were they were
like Li but only for a temporary period
and most of them have chosen not to
renew their licenses in New Hampshire
and those flexibilities were uh
capitalized upon benefited on by
Dartmouth health and other New Hampshire
based providers in those States Vermont
Massachusetts Maine okay absolutely
representative Schmidt and the
Manti thank you madam chair um so we're
going to make our decision based on
what's right for New Hampshire of course
but can you tell us uh how this
situation is being handled on a national
basis because telea health is obviously
expanding all over the place for obvious
reasons so what what is it like
nationally well as this committee well
knows lure is a state byst state uh
topic so the the federal government
currently reimburses for teleah health
coverage um and those that coverage
expansion or continuation of Tal covers
will expire and will need to be renewed
at the end of this year is my
understanding um but I don't think while
there's been discussions on the federal
level I'm not aware of any legislation
that has traction that would resolve
lure issues between the
states and it's not just doctors follow
so I mean I I used to live in I was born
and raised in Illinois and in Chicago as
a matter of fact and it's very very
close
uh to the state of Wisconsin which has
significant population in Racine and
kosha just across the border uh Gary
Indiana is Right close right next to to
Illinois to the South uh also lot of
Representative your your question so the
thing is this is a situation where very
analogous to what we have here where we
have a tremendous linkage between New
Hampshire and
Massachusetts uh but where these
ridiculous situations that we've heard
from the other Witnesses having to drive
across and sit in a parking lot trying
to get a connection with their doctor to
fulfill that imaginary line that
separates New Hampshire from
case yes I would believe so
representative manuti thank you Madame
chair thank you for taking my question
again I'll ask you about the reciprocity
you brought that up so our state of
Vermont uh do doctors are treating
patients across the border in Vermont
correct or the patient yes so you are
the research center up north just like
Mass uh Mass generalist for New
Hampshire south I mean New Hampshire
South so the compact it has to be both
ways so what is our at Avenue for
building that compact where is how would
this help with the compact for New
Hampshire to join we have joined the
compact for
Physicians it's been quite in place for
quite a while correct it's that
Massachusetts has not um uh so how do we
encourage our neighbors to the South to
join the
compact good question I'm sorry I don't
know the answer to that to answer your I
mean I actually thought during the
pandemic when there was the tremendous
amount of flexibilities granted
collaboration between the states that
that might provide a window that we
would see post pandemic we haven't seen
that so it is what it is Massachusetts
does what it want and we don't have much
control over it right just to But to
answer your initial question
a Dartmouth Health provider that's
licensed in the state of New Hampshire
can treat a Vermont patient who comes to
our Medical Center if that patient wants
to be treated in the state of Vermont
physically or be treated by their from
their home via tella Health our provider
either needs to have a license in the
state of Vermont or um have dual lure uh
now that we're past the
pandemic all right thank you other
questions thank you very much for your
testimony
is there anyone else who wishes to
302 seeing n I'll close the public
hearing and open the public hearing on
the non-gain amendment to Senate Bill
371 we will be voting on Senate Bill 302
this afternoon with our later today with
representative
Simon thank you madam chair I'll bring a
pin card back with me when I
come um so the amendment to SP 371 comes
at the request of oplc um it deals with
the licensing and regulation of
Physicians and uh follows the same
general outline of changing language uh
throughout are there copies of oh there
are and they're right next to Madam
chair I thank you thank you sorry I was
looking for mine I didn't I hopefully
everybody got the email did you get I I
did email that to the committee it okay
way well I did leave them at my seat so
muching I appreciate that representative
um so you'll see a lot of the same
language changes that we've been looking
at in general changing um things from
the board to the office where applicable
um there were a couple of more
substantive changes uh that I'd like to
draw your attention to page two line
21 um where it used to say the board may
it now says the office shall wave the
exemption requirement for any applicant
who has satisf satisfactorily passed all
examinations and requirements to become
board certified by the American Board of
Medical Specialists or by the American
osteopathic Association um talking with
the director um we couldn't come up with
a reason why um they shouldn't
automatically be Exempted or a case in
which they would not be Exempted and we
didn't want to leave open the
possibility for favoritism to somehow
show up um unnecessarily um or for
people to be treated differently
unnecessarily um so they always have
given the exemption we didn't see why um
that word shouldn't be changed to Shell
but the committee should be aware of it
um page three three line
25 um courtesy licenses are given for
100 days um and I know that uh there'll
be a comment about this later uh but I
just want to make sure that there was
substantially similar licensing as is
typical in a reciprocity statutes in
that uh even though they're only getting
a 100 day license that they should still
have substantially similar uh
qualifications to New Hampshire's
licensing requirements and then the
other more substantive change is just
down a little bit further in lines 34
and 35
uh instead of writing in the board on a
biannual basis for renewal of license
we've changed it in accordance with RSA
310a which deals with that but it's
already in statute so we're referring to
what's already in statute um but those
are the main changes other than
primarily language changes or if I
forget anything I'm sure the office will
be happy to point it out to you and I
all
amendment thank you madam shair uh with
me is Chelsea Nolan who's the director
of our who's the director of our
resident training program
we are addressing the amendment I'll be
very for the record my name is Matthew
Hood vice president of government
relations at Darth Health wanted to be
very clear that we have no position on
the amendment um our strong opposition
to striking the underlying bill is why
we are here um because of the challenges
in what the implications of a change or
or a lack of exception for
residency uh trainees would require so
we're here to speak to that and Miss
Nolan um can provide the details around
that
topic hi good morning uh my name is
Chelsea Nolan I'm the director of
operations for graduate medical
education at Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical
Center I want to make clear from the
beginning that Dartmouth Hitchcock
Medical Center has 450 some OD residents
and fellows 52 training programs and
we're providing care across uh again as
we've just talked about into Vermont um
where our residents have Vermont
training licenses and to be able to
provide tellah Health to the previous
bill um as well as providing care across
the Dartmouth Health System um and into
the various clinics in our state
additionally Beyond Dartmouth hitok
medical center training there are also
residents in training at Portsmith in at
conquered hospital and soon to be at
Treasure Medical Center in
Kean our concerns with regards to this
lure change that has happened with
regards to um moving from a four-year
renewal to a two-year renewal for all
licens types in the state of New
Hampshire
is that for residents and fellows who
are essentially apprentices in training
for a contracted period of time under
which their specialty requires a certain
number of years of training from one to
seven years this change moving from four
years for Renewal to a 2-year renewal
means that we are having to um have
those residents go through a renewal
process two or three times during their
residency
training at
present the new changes that have
happened at the oplc require that the
resident themselves create that app
compl complete that application obtain
the appropriate uh documentation from
their program director ensuring that
they are still within good standing
within their training program as well as
submit a $50 check which I've spoken
before about which they don't really
know what checks are any longer to be
honest um or a cashier check um to
submit that to the oplc to have a
renewal of their training license
what we are looking for at dhmc would be
to allow our residents and fellows and
the residents and fellows at psmith
conquered and treasure Medical Center to
be able to have a renewal process that
isn't as onerous to the resident trainee
who works upwards of 80 hours a week in
their specialty
training previously we've been able to
work with the oplc or the board before
it to provide a
renewal notice for all residents and
fellows to have that change happen in an
automated administrative way the changes
that have been made at the state level
are going to require that the resident
or do require now but may be moving to
an electronic system in which the
resident themselves is responsible for
creating or completing that
documentation and getting it to the
board um in the appropriate amount of
time as you can imagine these
individuals are highly uh stressed how a
lot of responsibilities on their plate
and our office as well as the offices at
our other gme um members across the
state are in support of all of the
requirements that they have to meet with
regards to Medicare and Medicaid to all
of their um New Hampshire drug
monitoring to flu etc etc and so we
really want to be able to continue to
support them in that work um and not
have it moved to them as being respons
the responsible party to ensure that
their license is in place the that is
the request that we are hoping that we
exception thank you we will be we will
be discussing it it's we can
certainly choose
to uh include the original content or
not that's up to our decision but thank
you for the information thank
you all right questions don't see any is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
on this amendment to house Senate Bill
371 ah the
oplc
yes director Courtney and Mr us okay yes
thank you we'll take
them good morning um Madam chair members
of the committee lindsy Courtney
executive director o PLC with me is
attorney Douglas osterhout um so uh
we support the amendment because I think
it it's intended to clarify the
legislative uh work that um e folks did
last year and will make our jobs easier
um implementing it as we move forward I
just want to address the underlying bill
um oplc is certainly amenable to you
know at times curving out exceptions we
understand that it's not always sure
that one sit fits all but I do want to
be careful that uh that the
justification for an amendment to our
licensure time frames um is not based on
um you know a desire to uh essentially
not have the lcy be obligated to to go
through the process the a professional
who has a license is responsible for
maintaining the continuing competence
and if that is the justification any
leny could make that same argument um
and we feel it's very important that the
leny understand their obligations at the
out set we have um many different
license types with many different
education levels you know people in high
school attending apprenticeship programs
people who have doctorates and the
message is the same which is that it's
your responsibility to maintain your
license so we're happy to work on
language that I think would be uh
amendable to all parties um but I think
we uh we would be concerned if we're
carving out an amendment for that
purpose be happy to are any questions
you may have thank you are there
questions no I think Ma your point thank
you very much thanks for your
testify all right seeing none I will
hearing and we have an executive session
scheduled at 11: I'd like to have a have
Republican caucus prior to
that so we'll
uh kick kick everybody out except the
Republicans and then we'll come back at
11: for our executive session thank you
much
e
all right thank good morning everybody
Welcome to our executive session before
we get going we are the lucky recipients
message all right we
have House Bill
1456 which is on the board of tax taxes
and land
appeals and the Senate decided
to make it a fiveyear term as we
discussed but didn't actually U make an
amendment to do so they also changed the
removal process
by citing the correct RSA that controls
the removal process rather than
duplicating the language so I'm going to
recommend to concur unless somebody on
the committee wants to change my mind
but it sounds like this is perfectly
harmless it's been known to happen I
said don't anybody do this okay it's
yeah it's it's a very reasonable
change and we we shouldn't argue with
them about it we're going to have enough
fun arguing about some of our other
things all right so Senate Bill 30 two
motion now you are all here you should
have a
right representative Schmidt moved out
to pass and representative Gould second
it do you wish to speak to your
motion thank you madam chair so this
seemed like a reasonable thing to do
thank
you thank you representative G you wish
I agree with um representative Schmid
and um yes certainly the my concerns are
for the Alzheimer patients and less
disruption in their in their treatment
routines and all of the testimony we
heard it was wonderful okay thank you
anyone else have a
comment questions representative sh
thank you madam chair I got so much
stuff here I need to get the mic closer
um yeah so many of our um how shall I
say Advanced Care type of
patients um just about have to go to
mass hospitals in order to get the care
that they need so it seems a reasonable
thing to do to
me okay represent bany thank you madam
chair I would hope that this
gesture uh will trigger the
reciprocity to the south of where I live
and uh the state uh south of where I
live so hopefully there'll be a
collaborative effort for the
betterment of everybody concerned I
represent man py I would strongly
recommend you not hold your breath while
you're
[Laughter]
waiting that's we we Mass Massachusetts
has a lot of Specialists and they are
they want to control the access to them
to some
else all right in that case the motion
is ought to pass on sen bable 302 and
the clerk can call the allall
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative sanon Sao yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Melvin yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Malloy yes
representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 20 a0 a all
right the motion passes 20 to zero does
anyone object to
consent no okay good we will put that
one on
consent
and Senate Bill 371 also from this
motion yes Madam chair I would like to
move Amendment
224-1
1671 there second
second
okay you wish to speak to your motion um
I would but I presented it to the
committee during the public hearing so I
would only be saying the same things all
over again so to save the committee time
Groen I have nothing to add okay thank
you um anyone else comments suggestions
questions
s my goodness everybody must be
hungry all right in that case the motion
is to adopt Amendment 1671 to Senate
Bill
371 and the clerk can call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Sasso yes representative
Dolan yes representative Melvin yes
clerk votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groda yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Malloy yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
man py yes and the chair yes 20a Zer
representative representative Simon
thank you madam chair I'll move a to
I'll second okay any any further
comments represent
Simon sure um so as written this bill
does replace the underlying bill um and
the committee should probably be aware
of of that
um it was uh it's a bit of a tricky Bill
uh as far as testimony was concerned we
had testimony this morning that
conflicted with previous testimony even
from the same organization that was
giving the testimony so did some last
minute juggling on that um the bill
itself would um give an exemption to the
2-year renewal process for lure for
Resident Physicians uh Physicians who
are in residency uh is probably clearer
way to put it um I have had another
discussion with the director from oplc
uh the way that the renewal process is
going to be mo happen moving forward um
addresses many of the concerns but maybe
not all the concerns that Dartmouth
Hitchcock had um
but it's a one-page renewal form it will
be a one-page renewal form it will be
electronic um it will have to be filled
out by the resident physician uh simply
because it will be attached to an
account specifically for that individual
um it should take less than 5 minutes
for the resident physici to fill out and
there should be an electronic form of
payment attached to that website so that
they don't have to worry about going out
and getting checks because as we've
heard in testimony this morning they
don't know what those are um which
there's a lot of Truth to that um that
should streamline that a little bit um I
guess I still feel and I want to assure
everybody I did look into it uh and have
further conversation but I still do feel
that if we're going to give an exemption
for lure uh it needs to be um a little
bit different other than you know
everybody's busy uh and I do appreciate
that I do appreciate that um but it is
not an onerous process um it does
require some responsibility I understand
that um but not such to the effect that
I think that it rises to the level of
exemption from the 2-year process so
recommendation yes I'd like to add that
in in in um addition to what
representative Simon says the um
Amendment brings these um parts of
Statute in compliance with um RSA I mean
with the house bill 655 in that it does
delineate the responsibilities between
the office and the board and cleans up
that
language okay thank you all
right anyone
else comments question all right the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
and the clerk can call theong
Representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative saso yes representative
Dolan yes representative Melvin yes CL
quote yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Malloy yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
manager py yes and the chair yes 20 a z
n all right motion passes 20 to Z any
objection to
consent seeing none we'll put it on
consent
all
485 you have motion I do oh I do have
Amendment um I'd like to
move Amendment 20
24 1610 H to house bills
485 is there a second second second
representative Brown seconds okay
representative groda
uh yes so in the last um one of the
tasks that the subcommittee had was to
compare Senate Bill 485 with House Bill
9585 that we passed through this
committee and when we did that there
were two sections that were left over
the digital um recognizable license and
the fact that
um military occup ational Specialties
could be included in this for boards
that are not required under o that are
not under
oplc and at the last right before the
last executive session where we were
going to entertain that Amendment we
found out from both Department of
informational technology and oplc that
digital verif digitally verifiable
licenses are not something that we can
quickly Implement with out
technology um
Investments so the committee and I
decided that we would take that part of
the amendment out so really what's left
is what's in front of you which is
something that can be that doesn't
conflict with the bill that we passed in
committee and actually adds to the
licensing for
veterans who have who fall under
oplc representative
Brown um I I would uh thank you madam
chair I would just add this brings a
full circle the conversation we had to
make sure
that those boards that aren't under
oplc will be required to complete their
rulem process for a crosswalk for
veterans and as if you remember we
decided not to do that in 1385 because
late yeah represent Mani thank you
Madame chair and you know if I recollect
the discussion it just uh highlighted
the weaknesses or deficiencies in our
systems which is the basic
infrastructure of um
um uh software Hardware digital
technology that's
um currently available and as a state we
are not there so this would if we had
followed what the amendment immed uh the
bill uh suggested we would not be the
oplc and the Departments could not I
mean boards could not comply with it so
that having said that I would say you
know not take your eyes off or your foot
bedal off of the infrastructure
underlying infrastructure that's needed
for 21st century so we can be compliant
and join the rest of the world thank you
thank you I think in in this case if we
were to do it immediately we'd be ahead
of the rest of the world which is one of
the reasons why we don't want to jump in
on
it anyone
that case the motion is to adopt
Amendment 1610 to Senate Bill 485 and
the clerk can call the role repres Simon
yes represent lakas yes represent Bailey
yes representative saso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Melvin yes B votes yes representative
voyd yes representative Brown yes
representative groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative sht yes representative
Malloy yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative
G she oh okay represent Smith yes
represent Manti yes and the chair yes 19
y z nay all
right representative yes U Madame chair
I move otpa a on Senate Bill
485 and I'll second that again okay any
further
comments I have nothing else to say
about nine lines thank you I agree
anyone have comments questions
concerns all right seeing none the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on Senate Bill 485 and the clerk can
call the RO representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Sasso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Melvin yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative
Gro yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Malloy yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative gold yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes in the chair yes 20 a0 and a
all right the motion passes 20 to Z is
there any objection to
consent
and for the information of those with us
we will be doing Senate Bill 440
last Senate Bill
488 representative Simon is that yours
yes representative laus
Sher oh representative G uh thank you
madam chair my apologies I move aop pass
for Senate Bill
second representative black seconds okay
do you wish to speak to your
motion thank you madam chair this bill
primarily cleans up some language
around two areas one is um remembering
and not opening my laptop here uh one of
them has to do with continuing
education uh that was just a change in
procedure that had happened and so it's
important we get something in statute to
allow OPC to follow up with physician
assistants who choose not to continue
some national
certification and there's a second part
to
it that I would have to look up I'll
look that up representative leus might
be able to help
thank you um right um I agree on the on
the first part uh the issue is to get
the initial licensing the Physicians
assistants need to have uh some national
certification they're not required to
maintain it that certification defines
containing medical education
requirements but if they choose not to
maintain the certification they have to
be defined somewhere and this uh has the
board toine them uh the second part is
that under the barbaran cosmetolog and
aesthetic
uh Physicians assistants that were not
they should have been but they were not
included in the exemption um to if it's
part of the medical procedure then cut
hair so if you fall down and split your
scalp open they're actually not breaking
the law if they trim the hair around it
it the The Barbers and cosmetologists
got and have a very broad scope of
practice and they're V Vigilant in
enforcing it
so okay any represent
Manti I I don't know if I should say
that but at least it'll be a very
expensive Barber or haircut if you're
going to a surgeon or a physician
assistant yeah well that's only only
when necessary I'm sure represent laus
yeah and even then they're only
permitted to do it if it's part of a
medical procedure so you could still not
go to them to have your haircut if
that's all you were having done
uh
yeah the uh the other thing is that this
allows the board to define the
continuing education requirements for
Physicians assistance as many of the
other boards do and it needs to be in
they need to have the authority to do
that because it's
important anyone else
comments
okay the motion is ought to pass and the
clerk call the role representative Simon
yes representative leakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Santo nasso yes representative Dolan
representative Melvin yes clerk vote Yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Maloy yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative gold yes
representative Smith yes represent Manti
yes and the chair yes 20 a0 n okay
motion passes 20 to Z any objections to
consent all right thank you we will make
do our best to make the this house
session on the 23rd no longer than
necessary House Bill
600 representative
alus Senate Bill 600 Bill 600
sorry uh I'd like to move to adopt if
you give me a moment I'll get the
amendment number when everyone should
have it uh Amendment 1737 H to Senate
Bill 600 I'll
second
um we should speak to your motion yes so
Senate Bill
600 for the uh amendment to have any
meaning we uh mention that uh
recently I guess in the last couple
years or so um there was I mean there
was regist or registration or
certification of pharmacy technicians
and there was um the ability for them to
be licensed was added and that's you
know additional training and
responsibility so I guess it was thought
that um if they're going to be uh
controlled by the Board of Pharmacy
there should be a pharmacy technician on
the board um so the underline board does
that and I can talk to that when we get
to the um to the bill itself um in the
original Bill there was an error um that
where it mentions who can be on the
board it only listed Certified Pharmacy
texts and it left out the licensed ones
which
are uh so this uh Amendment fixes that
um the other thing is that the prime
sponsor ask that we move the effective
date to January 1st of 2025 for two
reasons which the amendment does that
uh one is that um given the current
membership of the board and when people
are you know their terms are going to
expire it kind of just lines up better
uh but the other reason is that because
uh licensing to pharmacy technicians is
quite recent there are very few of them
currently um there's others going
through the process and so uh this would
provide time for there to be more
licensed pharmacy technicians who could
possibly serve on the board um and that
that's what you mment does
representative
gr I have nothing to add thank you does
anyone else have comments questions
concerns about the
amendment seeing none the motion is to
600 representative Simon yes represent
yeah representative lak sorry yes
representative Bailey yes representative
saso yes representative Dolan yes
representative Melvin yes clerk votes
yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative
goalie yes representative Shu yes
representative Malloy yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative manuti yes and
the chair yes 20 a0 n all right
representative laus I'd like like to
move uh ought to pass on Senate Bill 600
with
Amendment second second all right second
by representative goul slightly ahead of
Representative
broa representative
lais okay in addition to what I said uh
before this bill um as I said adds uh
one Pharmacy uh technician to the board
it also adds an additional pharmacist uh
because it's a good idea keep the number
of people on board on the board's odd to
avoid
ties and um in addition to the what I
mentioned before on the effective date
that's uh that's really all it does okay
representative
gold nothing further to say okay I'd
like to mention that we would like to
pass this bill because apparently the
dep Department of Justice doesn't know
how many me members are on the board and
so this will CL clarify
it we're just so helpful all right the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on Senate Bill 600 and the clerk can
call the RO representative Simon yes
representative lakus yes representative
Bailey yes representative saso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Melvin yes cler votes yes representative
Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Malloy yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitz Patrick yes representative Gould
yes representative Smith yes
representative manager py yes and the
chair yes 20 a0 a excellent all right
the motion passed 20 to zero any
objections to
consent okay we'll put it on consent and
I will like to introduce our substitute
members and I apologize for not doing it
sooner representative Malloy is in for
representative O'Brian and
representative Melvin is in for
representative
Gard all right and on Senate Bill
373 I'm going to move ought to
pass is there a second a
second okay
right
and this uh Bill changes the air leakage
requirements from and requires the
building code review board to make an
amendment
to increase the number of air the
minimum number of air changes from 3 to
five it used to be
seven U there are some issues with going
it as tight as three
and the latest version of the energy
code has five as the minimum required so
it is there is some science behind the
number and there are some issues with
overly tight homes uh
mold U outgassing of
materials that have caused a number of
organizations such as the CDC to
recommend against building homes that
tight and I suspect a lot of that is due
to people that don't realize they've got
to keep their ventilation running or
don't don't run their ventilation
properly because they're used to opening
the windows when they want fresh air and
letting the house leak so it's
a it's a change and I'm convinced the
building code review board did not
consider this as thoroughly as they
might because it was all wrapped up in
the debate on the energy code they
didn't didn't want to pick one piece of
the energy
code so that's why I'm in favor of it
representative Brown do you wish to
comment uh thank you madam chair I would
add there was a very reasonable
discussion about the extra cost that
this puts into building a home and the
extra cost into the testing of the uh
the amount of air exchanges if you don't
pass you have to test again and I forget
what that cost per test was but it was
had a thousand after it so that's a a
part of I think a major piece of the
concern for the the builders was the
cost of these uh going to staying at
three thank
you okay okay anyone else representative
goalie thank you madam chair I will not
be supporting this um just for a reason
of matter of principal as to how the
process works we put into process how
amendments are drafted for the building
code review board
um while it didn't pass the first time
around we heard discussion amongst those
members that were here who had testified
that they would be willing to work with
the individuals to get this through in
the proper procedures and done and I
would hope that we would at least intrum
study this and let it go through the
proper procedure to be brought forward
to this committee um the way every
amendment is done um and the way we all
agreed that the process should proceed
um and I think if we inm studied this we
can force the hand that they get back to
the table do the right thing and not
bring a piece of legislation forward on
behalf of a group that didn't get what
they wanted the first time around um for
that reason I will not support the aop
pass and I would hope we could intrm
study this let them do the proper
procedure and come back if it isn't done
I am more than willing to go forward
with this because I was one that stood
out and said that buildings were being
made too tight and I agree with them but
I just as a matter of principle that
they should follow the appropriate
procedures thank you thank you
representative
Simon thank you madam chair just because
I can't help but debate with
representative goolia it's too much fun
um my argument is that this is the
procedure um this is the this is the
procedure uh it was decided at one point
that the building code was just too
expansive for this particular committee
and the senate committee to look at uh
in its entirety and so we have given
power to uh the building code review
board to um look over the code and make
recommendation uh to the committee as to
what ought to pass um but ultimately
always um it is our job to ratify that
code ultimately always it is our
responsibility um to determine what goes
into statute and all code does go into
statute that's what we do when it comes
before us every single time um this
particular piece of the code
was heavily debated on the in the
building code review board most of the
time when we get the code it's uh
unanimous so it's it's easy um to just
ratify those things this was not uh it
was heavily debated they couldn't come
to an agreement on it and so somebody's
B us a piece of that um for our
consideration and as I said to uh Mr
Sherman who's the head of the building
code review board although it would be
very difficult for this committee to
wrap its head around every piece of code
and and do that well we can certainly
wrap our head around a piece of code uh
and the lications of it and make a
decision they're still doing their job I
feel like we're still doing our job in
that process um and I just don't want to
see us abdicate that or and I don't
think this is actually what
representative goalie was saying so I
don't want to put words into his mouth I
just don't want to become a rubber
stamping agent for the building code
review board um where we agree with what
they agree with and disagree with what
they disagree with uh and I'll close by
basically saying if in the presentation
of the building code review board to
this committee we disagreed with
something that they had done this is
exactly the process that we would take
to remedy that um we would make an
amendment we would bring it back to
committee we would discuss it we would
pass it um because ultimately the um the
process leads through the legislature so
much and I will mention that the
legislature has made specific technical
changes to the State Building Code
repeatedly um the last one I I remember
was the ark
fault U outlets in the electrical code
we said they don't work for you you can
replace
them uh 15 years ago we said we will not
mandate Sprinklers and we will not let
towns mandate sprinklers in single
family homes because after consideration
we decided the cost and benefits didn't
balance
properly uh and there have been been
other cases but those two are are U are
firm it is our job not as representative
Simon said not just to agree with what
the building code review board does but
to think about it and if
they left a piece out or didn't make an
amendment we we uh legislation is the
way to change
it but anyway anyone
oh representative G has a
comment Madam chair I
wondered regarding the bill I support
this more ventilation I don't like
airtight houses I also though have um
proposal to add um I'm not sure if it's
called an amendment or an addition to
this bill it would be an amendment an
amendment to take the language from
House Bill
1252 which this um committee and the
Full House passed but it failed in the
Senate and added to this bill okay and
1252 is that is to form a study
Hampshire no no my motion was off to
it is there a second to representative
who
right I'm so sorry could I have a
clarification the it's not to replace no
this is just okay okay thank you then I
do second I have the the speaker and the
clerk have
issued uh ground rules for silly silly
season amendments since this bill passed
this committee we can attach it to any
other bill in our committee if it were
to be a floor Amendment it could be
attached to anything at all because it's
past the house it's re it's it is
Germain but any other committee can't
pick it up it would have to be on the
floor and I could add that this bill
also passed the house correct that's why
it's Germain okay all right thank you
yes it has passed the house therefore
it's Germaine to
anything we can do it in our
committee um it could be done as a floor
Amendment either
way all right representative
Schmidt so I will not be supporting this
motion uh and the reason is that we
overlooked a very important fact uh when
we heard this bill
okay not really right and that was that
there were 40
people watching
online 40 people and uh we did not and
we we should when the chair acknowledged
this subsequent in discussion that we
should pay attention to what the uh not
everybody's going to come to conquer
okay uh but of the 40 people who are
watching the vote was 38 nay and two yay
on
this and the people who were watching
were a number of people who were
indigenous people members of the uh
Native American uh commission and so
forth uh and we we were totally blly
unaware of that because we did not pay
any attention to it and we need to start
doing that this is an our our
opportunity to to reflect what the
people who paid attention to this bill
and voted if you will online said 38 n
to Y so uh and representative Maguire
and I were two of the people in
committee who voted no on
1252 so we made a mistake by not being
in fully informed and this is our
opportunity not to make the same mistake
again
Madame chair may I
speak yes Madam representative G I'm
sorry I didn't ask you to speak to your
your Mo your motion thank you madam
chair uh yes this bill was something
that um was recommended after last year
a bill that uh that I put in for um for
recognition of Native Americans and this
committee heard the bill they heard the
testimony they were aware of some
opposition and considered all the
factors and it passed um I believe it
was 18-2 it went to the floor and it
passed almost unanimously on voice there
were maybe four or five Nays so um I
think it's something that is very
important as I've said in the past the
experience is that we have no study
committee ever on record for Native
Americans and while we can just go ahead
informally like we did after last year
to form this bill um it leaves no record
for the future for people to go back and
look at what was the study committee's
recommendations so I would like I would
hope to have people's support thank
you represent Bara you wish to speak to
it I
do I'd like to
correct my friend from
do because during the Committee hearing
and during the
executive session he mentioned this 38-2
Vote many times and I for one did not
make a mistake when I supported this
bill in the first time and the reason
why and I was very explicit about this
that it was my intention to pass both
the bill that had to do with the
commission and this study committee
because I was not going to take sides on
who was what when
where so
I am in full support of this of adding
this and if the Senate the Senate didn't
agree and I'm sorry that they didn't but
they either go together or they don't go
at all that is the way I feel about it
and I think that this is the best Avenue
for us to follow thank
you representative leus uh thank you
madam chair um so I was uh sponsor of
this bill and at this point I'm torn
um I do think it would be reasonable to
pass this I'm a little concerned about
complicating um 373 by adding this on
and I've been going back and forth on
this and I think on balance I'm I'm prob
I'll vote for this um and uh see what
happens thank you okay
well I'll I'll go on to say that I'm
also concerned with
affecting um Senate Bill
373 and I voted against the study
committee in the first place
because this is within the scope anybody
can study it what they like and this is
I don't think we need any more formal
study
committees anyone else representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair
so um the testimony in the Senate and I
was one of the people who testified but
the shair of the of the Native American
commission was there she she was online
one of the people who voted against it
online one of the 38 okay she was there
and several other former or current
members of the commission were there and
they testified against this in the
Senate that's one of the reasons that
the senate committee voted
itl and that one of the statements that
was made was that the study committee
that this bill would form is
antithetical to the good order and
discipline if you will of the
commission that was a testimony of
people who are on the commission
including the chair before the Senate
that's the reason one of the reasons
that they voted against
so I think we're just we're asking uh
and and I and those are the people who
are the experts on the indigenous
matters and we should not uh o overrule
them in my judgment thank you
i' I'd like to mention that I have been
informed that we can't actually adopt
this until we have a formal Amendment
which
will which could be obtained this
afternoon so if we decide if we vote in
favor of adding this we will have to do
that vote after we get the amendment
which should be quick since it's since
it has to be what pass the house but uh
another
Madam CH people should be aware of it
yes can I just follow up on one more
comment thank you I just like to say
that um in response to uh what
representative groa said my colleague
from wherever she's
from that I I um I would like to rise
I'd like to agree that we um worked very
hard to make this a collaborative
project and that we um had a member of
the commission agree to work with you
know we all work agreed to work together
and we did work together something
happened I don't know what happened I
don't want to speculate I don't want to
guess what people's purposes or motives
were all I know is we all came together
we all agreed on two bills being both
passed and moving ahead and then there
was a change on one party uh and which I
can't understand but I really appreciate
the opportunity to be able to get a
study committee on the record because
some of this confusion and back and
forth just makes things difficult and
when we can all come together officially
under an official study committee it
will all be on the record and there
won't be he said she said kind of stuff
so thank you okay anyone else
representative
Brown uh thank you madam chair so I
would be really concerned about 373
being derailed
uh that's if if that passes that's a
direct impact to the cost of
housing that is is good for the citizens
in New Hampshire so I representative G
if is is there any way that this could
be brought up next year it could be I'm
sure but would that be a problem I'm I
have a I'll reiterate that again the 373
and and the air exchanges and the cost
to housing is really an important thing
we don't want to lose
okay anyone else have a comment repres
man a clarification uh Madam chair so
even if we vote on it we have to take an
official vote once we get which means
this
afternoon we hopefully we would be able
to get it this
afternoon okay because this is the LA
this is this is the last day that we
have that I have scheduled for this
committee
except for a um something to deal with
the um interim study bills sometime in
today thank you madam CH
okay anyone else have any all right
let's let's take a straw poll on the
idea of adding the content of house
built
1252 to Senate B Bill
favor all right there are 11 in
favor obviously that leaves nine
opposed
um Mr Greenland if you could arrange to
get such an amendment
drafted as quickly as
possible we will recess this
amendment Senate Bill 318 representative
leus uh yes as soon as I get all right
I'd like to
I'll
second you wish to speak to your motion
I do
so um you know earlier in the year we
dealt with House Bill 1271 which changed
a number of boards to advisory made
certain other changes um there were some
concerns about some of those boards and
we ended up interim studying that
bill U the intent for creating the
amendment on this bill was to take
um certain things out of there the uh
manufactured housing uh standards
installation Standards Board and the
board examiners of nursing home
administrators and change those to
advisory boards another thing was that
um there's the existing advisory boards
a massage
therapists
um and uh actually I've got it here
anyway there there's two other boards
that would be combined there're already
advisory boards and um and that was at
the request of those two boards
um and then and basically that was it
and unfortunately when OS drafted the
amendment they left significant pieces
out of they were supposed to take those
pieces out of
1271 apply the P those equivalent pieces
from the proposed amendment to 1271 and
create this amendment out of it um
unfortunately U there were a lot of
chunks uh that were left out and um I
went through it and actually I would
want to thank uh Doug osterhout from uh
oplc who who I asked to review it and he
found those pieces so anyway 1780 is
what the amendment was intended to be
and so and this replaces the entire Bill
actually what I should say is the
underlying Senate Bill 318 is on uh so
the social work compact the language is
identical to the house bill 1190 which
has already been been um uh passed by
the house and the Senate um and so
passing that again would would not make
sense
so um the two boards the uh manufactured
housing installation board and the
nursing home administrators board the
subcommittee went through those in a lot
of detail and um you know looked at the
makeup the proposed makeup of the boards
and made changes to that um the other
changes in here are uh there are some
that are the
general um cleanup of the language some
of what was in uh HP 655 from last year
there's some of that but the main point
is to make them advisory boards and then
as I said the
um get the names right the
uh there's the board of massage
therapists and then the board of U
reflexologist yeah it's a reflexologist
structural inter ators and Asian body
work therapists they're combined and the
new board will be called The Advisory
Board of massage therapists reflexes
structural integrators and Asian
Bodywork therapists and again that one
was at the request of those boards the
other thing that I took out of the
original Senate Bill 318 is all
reference to um medical technician
registration so we had um House Bill
1410 which got rid of that because it
was not
working um and that went to the Senate
and the Senate has decided that um they
want to retrain retain registration they
recognize the issues that we
saw um and I as I understand it they're
looking at um keeping uh registration
for medical technicians but get rid of
the board and have the rul making and
other processes uh just directly under
the office U of Professional Licensing
and certification so I took it out at
318 so it not confli with what the
Senate appears to be doing and that's
represent I'd also like to add that you
might all remember the amendment to um
House Bill
1095 and how this the language in this
bill is in compliance with the language
that we have in other boards now so we
should have most of our
um
statutes by the end of this
session
aligned and I think that's also very
important so thank you okay anyone else
represent man py thank you madam chair
um I remember the hours of subcommittee
work on this and uh pulling apart pieces
and putting it together thank you
representative laus for your patience on
doing that together together and I do uh
appreciate the fact that we are only
looking at the boards that uh changed
from regulatory to advisory upon their
request not force the others that did
not want we heard a lot of boards that
did not want to become an Advisory board
for their profession and um I appreciate
the fact that we were able to
incorporate that with this and uh also
the point of that has been my con um pet
peeve in terms of saying not the
individual but the office of the oplc or
the licensing board putting as a body in
respon responsible not individual
heading
any organization so I appreciate both
those so I will support
this thank you representative Shu thank
you madam chair um I just basically want
to uh Echo representative mapi's
statement uh as someone who opposed the
original passage of House Bill
1271 I do appreciate representative
leakes's work to take out the items that
were objected to and I appreciate his
yeah thank you for that and I also
wanted to thank everybody on the
subcommittee this this was a lot of work
getting through 1271 and everybody
participated in it and that was good yes
I'd like to mention that we'll also make
the infm study of 1271 a lot easier
because we've eliminated some of
the U non-controversial sections and
this the interim study can concentrate
on what the requirements are for the
remaining boards rather than look look
at combining the massage therapy and the
B Asian body
work anyone
else okay the motion is to adopt
Amendment
1780 to Senate Bill 318 and the clerk
can call the role representative Simon
yes representative lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Sasso yes representative Dolan yes
representative
yes clerk votes yes representative Boyd
yes representative Brown yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes representative
Malloy yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative gold yes representative
Smith yes representative Manti yes and
the chair yes 2a0 a okay represent black
I'd like to move ought to pass with
Amendment for uh Senate Bill
318 okay is there a second I'll second
okay you wish to speak to your motion uh
given that the amendment replaces the
bill and we discussed it I don't think
we need anything
else okay anyone else comments questions
concerns okay the motion is ought to
pass with Amendment on Senate Bill 318
and the clerk can call the word
represent Simon yes represent lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Sasso yes representative Dolan yes
representative Melvin yes clerk vot yes
representative voyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Malloy yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 20a Z all
right motion passes 20 to zero uh any
objections to
consent okay we'll put this one on
consent on a roll and that leaves Senate
Bill
440 representative
leus I'd like to adopt amendment
185h to Senate Bill
440 okay is there a second I'll second
so I mean the underlying bill would
allow um optometrists to do some
additional procedures um there was a lot
of concern raised about them potentially
doing it without adequate um education
training and all
so that was you know we had the sub the
subcommittee work session on it I'd like
to thank everybody who is working on
that
and um so there were um some changes I
mean the first part of this amendment is
just a little bit of a cleanup on the uh
language on the list of procedures are
not permitted to do as I understand it
this part was uh you know there was
agreement between the optomologist and
the optometrist that's what I heard um
and it's just some uh more like
technical changes to descriptions and
names the
substance is um on the second page
starting at
uh I'm sorry
yeah uh yeah the starting at line
and it's it's the uh what what the board
has to do around
rulemaking and it says uh they shall
have the authority to determine what
conss of practice Optometry by person's
license in the chapter consistent with C
curriculum of nationally accredited
schools but in
particular they have they shall they
must adopt rules uh establishing the
credentialing credentialing
certification which shall be uh
fulfilled before a person may be
certified to perform optomic procedures
and there are given a list of things
they must do one is identification and
categorization of optomic procedures for
the practice of Optometry what we heard
and both in the public hearing and in
subcommittee is there's a large list of
potential procedures
and um so they have to group the ones
that they want optometrist to be able to
do um you know in categories and then
they have to establish the criteria for
performing such procedures with
proficiency um that's got to include a
minimum education training and live
experience requirements for a person to
perform such procedures with efficiency
there was concern expressed about um um
optometrist potentially only um
practicing on in animate objects whether
it's uh you know from animals or uh or
you know synthetic uh
simulations and um you know and so this
requires that they actually have live
experience requirements it also is a
criteria it says for a proctoring
criteria for acquiring such proct in
other words when they're
doing um this kind of clinical work when
they're they're uh getting their
practice on on live patients they're
going to have somebody watching what
they're doing uh presumably as part of
the training and to make sure they're
they're doing it correctly so the
details on that must be done in
rules and U
so and then also on the next page uh
Roman 2 it says no optometrist shall
practice under this section unless the
optometrist has submitted evidence of
satisfactory completion of all
requirements for spefic spefic
procedures and the office has certified
that and um also a little below that in
section 12 it makes it explicit that if
a uh optomet optometrist uh performed
any of the procedures for which they had
not been certified as having met the uh
requirements that would be a a a you
know an a disciplinary offense and they
could be sanctioned for that you know up
to it including uh losing their license
um and so you know we heard uh concerns
that um you know there it wasn't clear
you know how they would get the training
and all of that and and you know that
may be true but until there is a clear
definition of what the education
training requirements
are um and that's aist process to
rulemaking so uh anybody can be involved
that I expect both optometrist and
opthalmologists will be involved in that
process process and we heard testimony
from the optometrist that they intend to
um use as a you know uh at least a guide
or starting point for what the training
and uh and other requirements would be
training education all that would be
based on what opthalmologists are
required for those particular procedures
I mean they wouldn't have all the
training an opthalmologist would have
but then again their scope would
practice would still be dramatically
less than that of an
MD um and so that would be and until
that is done until the ru making is done
and until there are optometrists who
have met those requirements no
optometrist is going to be able to do
anything they they aren't doing today
and so this is uh not letting all the
optometrist Loose as soon as this uh
goes into effect to do whatever they
want but it sets in place a process to
Define what are the Education and
Training requirements are going to have
to meet
including um working on live uh people
under
supervision and that's the key part of
the bill there's um if you look in on
page three line Sorry line
21 um there's some technical changes
similar to what we've done on other
bills and um you know House Bill 655
last year clarifying what's the
responsibility of the board and what's
the responsibility of the office and
those changes in that section where the
request of
um and also the
uh U you know the board will Define the
details on the requirements for uh
continuing
does represent Andre py thank you madam
chair thank you uh for that detail
explanation representative leers oh
excuse me
I'm sorry do you mind letting CL finish
you oh I was just speaking to my second
okay so um what I want to say is
that I want everyone to understand that
Ru making is not a
joke it is
totally um in it's an intense
process and that anyone who minimizes
rule making or thinks that this is some
willy-nilly thing that op Autometrics
are going to be able to do they're
incorrect so I think that people should
realize that rul making is something
that is always happens as a result of
legislation in things that and and it's
very common in
licensing and
this committee has support Ed
boards and they the importance that they
have in their
expertise and we ask them to put that
expertise in writing through rule making
so I don't want anyone to walk away from
here and think
that rule making is just going to be a
couple of check boxes filled out and
that's going to be the end of it it's
serious
stuff and I'm glad that it's in here and
and I think that it's an important part
you thank you madam s sorry for jumping
the gun um couple of things and for me
it still I've toiled with a lot of this
uh about this bill and I think um
echoing uh representative gr's uh s
um points that Ru making has not not
already happened and we are not just
adopting something that's already been
uh you know proposed by one group or the
other and I still very firmly believe
this will only
enhance the opportunity for the granite
Staters to get preventive early
intervention and access to I care based
on very solid grounds of what the
training is who's looking at it and so I
would and it'll take a year or so to do
the ru making and you know working
collaboratively and I still firmly
believe that this will remove the silos
of SP this is my territory this is yours
kind of thing is it will definitely
enhance collaborative effort thank you
and I will be supporting them
representative
Goldie thank you madam
chair I will not be supporting
this we look at what we do here when we
do licensing and it's
safety
and there was some discussion
that only two schools in the country out
of the
22 that do instructing have actual
clinical experience
required and specifically there was one
here from Kentucky when it
testified was asked what the minimum was
that someone had to do to be considered
proficient or the maximum and there was
so there's no guidance as to what
proficiency means you can say we're
going to put it in
rules but there's no criteria out there
programs we are not the medical experts
we had folks sitting here on this
committee from Health and Human Services
from the medical
field and one of them representative
Murphy I asked specifically last week at
session how he felt about this bill and
he didn't feel comfortable with it and
Madam chair with these folks were here
for a reason to get their input and my
question I guess goes to representative
leus was their input brought forward
after the subcommittee met on how they
amendment black right
um I did not talk to them specifically
and I wasn't contacted however uh there
was communication with certainly a lot
from the opthalmologists and also the
optometrists and I mean it's recognize
there are limited places for or schools
for people to get this training at this
time um and but the concerns raised
about that were were certainly
recognized I think addressed in this
amendment um you know there's going to
be input from opthalmologist and whoever
else is interested on the ru making and
their char
charged to um Define what adequate
training is or what the proper training
is for them to become proficient uh
there is a requirement that was added
partly in response to the concerns that
were raised that it include U you know
live practice on people under
supervision and um and it may be that
there are
um you know not very many people who've
come out of schools already maybe nobody
who's will be able to meet the
requirements that end up in rules but
the uh we you know we've heard there are
uh expansions in this because there are
more states that are permitting some of
these additional uh
procedures and if somebody's had the
training but they haven't had the live
practice there are options there may be
it's going to depend on rules um a
situation where that person that
optometrist would work closely with an
opthalmologist to uh get that clinical
practice on live people under
supervision with that opthalmologist
there's a number of
possibilities and the expectation I have
is that the number of optometrists that
are going to be able to do these new
things will grow slowly but as somebody
had had said in in one of the uh
hearings it's to some extent a chicken
and egg problem right now a lot of the
schools are not providing this training
because either in the because the state
where the school is it's not legal for
them to do it so they can't um or
because um a lot Most states it's not
legal and so there's no point uh but
there's um as we heard 12 States and if
New Hampshire you know Hampshire might
add to that where some or all of these
procedures have become legal but it is
it'll be a process of growth of uh the
education or training require you know
opportunities coming to be um and we did
hear from the optometrists on the board
uh who are actually on the board now
uh that uh the intent at least as a
start for the rules is the um the level
of
training and uh including uh clinical
work required for the of the
opthalmologist for those specific
procedures uh but as an opthalmologist
can do many other things on the eye and
is fact they're MDS and they can do any
general um uh you know procedure that U
medical doctors can do they can under
under the law under licensing they may
choose not to to um but anyway I mean
the this sets the framework in place to
set out the rules and requirements for
the training uh Education and Training
and as that uh training becomes
available um then people will be able to
take advantage of it if and if it
doesn't then optometrists aren't going
to be able to do anything new uh but
unless we allow this opportunity then
that rest of that is not really going to
be able to develop representative Simon
thank you madam chair uh two things
briefly um first uh not that the debate
hasn't had to do with the amendment um
but uh when looking at the amendment
my kind of uh opinion on it is
regardless of whether you share
representative goal's concerns the
amendment is much better than the
underlying bill at uh delineating those
things and and for that reason I think
it's worthwhile to adopt the amendment
and perhaps debate more fully the
underlying Bill uh the second thing was
just a clarification to something that
representative Lea said earlier on the
on page one on the list of
exclusions
[Music]
um I don't I don't think that it would
be a fair um I don't think it would be
fair to say that the opthalmologists
were like support of the in support of
the list they're not really in support
of anything so um what it is is in the
process of the conversation some things
were said the optometrist took those
into consideration changed some of the
language to strengthen it to hope
hopefully meet some of the concerns that
the opthalmologist had uh certainly line
29j in particular um I can attest to
having had a conversation with an
opthamologist that language around the
orbit of the eye is much more acceptable
and much more restrictive than the
original language was so it certainly
does take his concern into uh account
and change it to make it stronger um but
I still have a feeling that if I gave it
to him he wouldn't stamp it and say
we're for it okay representative
Dolan thank you Madam chair um my
comment is for the underlying Bill not
just the amendment you want me to to
wait if you don't mind okay
representative Shu thank you madam chair
um I'll make all my comments at this
time I will be voting for the amendment
uh as representative Simon indicated I
feel that it does make the bill better
and I do appreciate concerns expressed
at the hearing about access to care
however I don't feel that the one very
lengthy subcommittee meeting that this
committee held was enough to dive into
all of the procedures involved in this
bill and I would hope that we could
possibly send the underlying Bill to
interim study for this process to
further examine these very complicated
issues thank
you represent ative Schmidt and then
Brown thank you madam chair uh well I
certainly want to commend representative
leus for uh for all the work you've done
uh and I think we are getting
closer uh to uh what where we need to
get to uh but um I recall several years
ago when we were dealing with an issue
involving the disability community and
they came before us and very
passionately
advocated with one phrase that I've
never forgotten and it said nothing
about us without
us and they said about the bill we were
dealing with at that
time it was something about them without
them um and so this new amendment I
think is is a definite
Improvement what I'm concerned about is
that we are legislating
over the top of
the HHS committee which
has the purview of medical stuff our
purview in portfolio is rules and
Licensing and so forth and we are going
in the right definitely going in the
right direction with regard to that but
we have some
opthalmologists uh have they seen this I
don't know
uh but I I I think that you you said it
a moment ago or couple of minutes ago
represent leus that um uh that you had
uh heard from some
opthalmologist uh you've heard about
some of the things uh and this gets more
specific but uh uh I I think we have not
had a good enough procedure or process
yet we're getting there but I'm not
ready to rush with somebody something
dealing with the human eye it's one of
our most important organs uh most
sensitive organs and uh and I I don't
want to do anything until we've had more
subcommittee work on this amendment to
see whether it gets there so I I I will
support this amendment because it makes
the the underlying Bill better that's
for sure but will I support the uh
underlying Bill the
otpa not not until I've heard from the
opthalmologist because we have to have a
collaborative practice with with them as
well as with the optom representative
Brown and then leus um representative
leus may go ahead of me if he wishes to
respond to it thank you um first on on
what Reverend Simon said I don't want to
put words in uh the opthalmologist mouth
actually I got that list from him after
he talked to the opthalmologist
optometrist probably a better way to say
it is that uh they both thought that the
uh the changes in this list of what they
shall not do was an
improvement um not that uh you know
that's what they they wanted to see go
into law
um and you know passing this bill the
amendment of the bill um isn't the end
of the procedure I don't the question is
what would we do if we were to do
further work um you know you said we're
not you know we're not medical doctors
uh much of H of the HHS committee isn't
either although some are um and it would
you know coming up with the detailed
rules on what procedures they may and
may not do what procedures um what the
training would have to be for that is I
don't think within the expertise of this
um uh Committee just like the detailed
rules of what the electrical code should
be is not or or what it takes to be a
license electrician isn't what we do in
general is we set up a
framework um and then we leave it to
rulemaking and I believe this bill does
or the with the amendment it does a good
job of that um you know there were some
general kind of overarching concerns
about optometrists doing things that
they did not have the training for um I
certainly wouldn't want them doing that
and this puts in requirements including
one that was raised quite a bit about
you know live practice it puts that in
as a requirement for the ru making so it
sets a a
framework in place for the ru making and
that process would continue I'm sure as
a collaborative process between the
opthalmologist and the optometrist um
and this list of what they may not do is
just setting kind of a firewall be you
know that even under the rulemaking and
all that they can't go beyond this point
um which are more uh more serious uh um
operations so that's you know that's my
take on it represent
Brown uh thank you madam chair so
originally I was very much against this
um and then uh working through the
subcommittee and and I'll thank our
optometrist and opthalmologist because
there was a couple of interesting
conversations and our
subcommittee
um it became really clear to me that I
don't think that we as a
committee addressing representative
shu's comment I don't think that I can
answer in seven years of surgical
residency how many times has an
opthalmologist practiced with a scalpel
on a live person and is that particular
practice a general practice with a scalp
and or a
laser is all of that amount of time
practice necessary to do X Y or a
procedure that we're that they're asking
to do we don't know that at this point
and we certainly don't know the other
side of that as as was already mentioned
that there's very little live practice
in most Optometric
schools so how long would it take this
committee to understand that it would
take I I think
and would we get a consistent answer so
I am my originally I was against this I
am now going to vote for it with the
understanding from our subcommittee I
are are very much willing to make sure
that any procedure that they're going to
do meets at a minimum some type of
surgical
skill General surgical skill and then
surgical skill with the procedure in
general or the specific procedure excuse
me so because of that I'm going to
support the amendment representative
Smith thank you madam chair uh I agree
with representative go go goola goalie
I'll get it uh I'm not going to support
this bill what I would like to see this
done uh what I'd like to see happen to
this is to go to interim study I I don't
think any of us are completely
100% understanding and and we there are
no guidelines as to how many times like
um representative Brown said how many
times they have done a particular
procedure did are they fast learn
Learners are they slow
Learners we have no guides I don't know
how you get those but I think until we
do we don't really have a good consensus
as to what's going on here and
I will vote against it represent man py
thank you madam chair I just having been
on the subcommittee and having worked
closely with um the subcommittee members
I want to point out the reason I am
looking at this as a step in the right
direction is that both opthalmologists
and optometrist are professionals right
with training and both have the vote to
Public Safety and from what I took away
from the public hearing was that not
optometrists are not running to hang
their uh um name out to say I'm ready to
do surgery they're taking the process
also give us the opportunity to get in
that direction because the uh procedures
and the technology has changed and the
education is changing so and to adapt to
that and giving that professional
courtesy the ru making giving them the
direction we are not I'm not an
apologist I don't understand the details
of it but at least knowing that the
board of
optometrist the board is willing to put
the time and effort into set that rule
making keeping the Public Safety in mind
and working collaboratively to get the
help or support from the opthalmologist
this is setting
up that opportunity to work
collaboratively having worked in the
health field I feel like you know we've
gone so much uh into the Super specialty
and gotten to a point where the
collaborative effort has to come back to
Patient centered and with that in mind I
think this is the step in the right
direction we could study all we want
and how long will it take is the thing
so with that I will be supporting this
and I just want to articulate that we
are dealing with professionals and give
that credit and respect thank you okay
representative
thank you madam
chair I just want to talk a little bit
about we talk about Public Safety as we
go
forward and we've
had a subcommittee meeting in one week
to work on
this this isn't an easy subject we heard
from one of the schools that was here
there's only two schools in the country
that give clinical exp experience going
forward
we're talking about the rul making
procedure and that no optometrist is
going to be able to come forward right
away with the experience needed to do
these
procedures I don't understand why we are
pushing this through
today and not doing the appropriate work
and bringing these two groups together
because I think there is some common
ground on what procedures can be done
Manner and why we can't intrum study
this because it's been said numerous
times no optometrist is going out the
door once this passes doing these
procedures so for that reason I still
will not vote for this hoping that we do
the right thing do inum study really
look at this see where the common ground
is and not rush this through thank
you Simon thank you madam chair just um
appreciating uh the full debate of the
committee as we head towards the vote I
just want to refocus a little bit um and
make sure everybody is thinking about
the fact that the first vote will be on
the amendment and whether or not you're
for or against the underlying Bill if
your concern is Public Safety you still
want this amount this amendment so I
don't want that to get lost in the
shuffle of the debate of the underlying
bill um this amendment certainly does
improve the bill overall um regardless
of your position so please keep that in
consideration when you go to make your
vote okay representative gold thank you
madam chair I'd like to thank
representative leus for his leadership
on the subcommittee and all of the
parties for coming to the meetings and
sharing a lot of good information with
us just like I talked about in terms of
the Chicken and the Egg with the schools
you can't expect schools to develop
programs with live um results when it's
illegal to do and when there's not a
market for it because the states aren't
allowing it to happen I would also say
you can't expect a bill to come forward
here that where all the rules and
everything's been laid out when we
haven't even passed a bill to allow the
process to get started so again we're
talking about a Chicken and the Egg and
of course it'll be the Department of
Health and Human Services it'll that has
to do with the medical technical
procedures
and I don't care how long we study it
that's not what this committee's role is
it goes beyond the scope of our
committee to think we're going to get
our head around what is the safety of
medical practices but to get our head
around how you set up licensing and how
you set up that process of rulle making
I think we've looked at this enough to
be able to make that decision so I'll be
supporting this amendment and I'll be
supporting the underlying bill so that
we can move ahead for the safety of
patients so they can get into get
surgery thank you I'd like to mention
that the uh the governor has
decided as of yesterday to get involved
in this and he is encouraging the
optometrists and the opthalmologists to
work together uh if that were to happen
and they come up with some revised
language that is agreeable to both
parties I have committed to putting it
into a floor Amendment and bringing it
to the house because we will be voting
on this on the
23rd If they don't agree come up to any
agreement and they haven't yet because
they haven't haven't yet met well we
have to deal with what we have on
hand but I just thought you should know
that there is a possibility of a floor
Amendment which I will be sharing with
the committee prior as soon as I know
what it
is anyone else question to the chair yes
sir so
uh does that mean you're we are not
going to proceed with a vote on this no
no no no at this time or no sir it means
that we are going to proceed with a vote
on what we have I'm just warning you
that the governor is meddling and if the
optometrist and the optomologist happen
to agree on something that they want to
include in the bill I will be bringing
it forth as a floor Amendment thank you
for that clar they do not agree well
that's where we are now but one never
knows they
might indeed one never
knows anyone
else okay the motion is to adopt
Amendment
1815 to Senate Bill 440 and the clerk
can call the role representative Simon
yes representative lakus yes
representative Bailey yes representative
saso yes represent Dolan yes represent
melan yes clerk V representative Boyd
yes representative Brown yes
representative groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie no
representative Shu yes representative
Malloy yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative gold yes representative
Smith yes representative manip py yes
and the chair yes 19 yay one nay all
right we have adopted the amendment
representative leus
yes I'd like to move ought to pass with
Amendment for um Senate Bill 440
second okay representative leus second
by representative
Gould is there any you wish to speak to
the the concerns that uh we heard I
think um were in my view addressed by
this amendment at least to get the
process in place uh the only thing I'll
say again is is that um you know there
it is setting in place an ongoing
collaborative agreement which I'm sure
the ru making will be and um you know I
don't in in considering interim study I
don't
know what else we would want to do here
um you know as as representative Brown
uh said you know we're not qualified to
get into the exact details that the rul
making would involve unless we're all
going to go to medical school first
and I believe that's true also of HHS I
mean I don't know if there's any
opthalmologists on there maybe there are
but certainly most of the committee is
not that or MDS and so there's going to
have to be a lot of drawn out discussion
on the particular procedures what are
their training requirements what are
going to be the requirements for the
number of live uh you know clinical
practice uh procedures and all that sort
of thing and I don't think an interim
study that's something that this
committee could do or any Committee in
the house could do so um I'm I ask
people to support um passing this uh
you
and unless the second person needs
to thank you this has been going on too
long represent do you wish to speak to
your second uh thank you madam chair no
I think um representative Le has said it
well okay representative Dolan and then
man py thank you madam chair um my my
thoughts are that with an abundance of
caution and Public Safety in mind with
eye
surgery I'm in favor of restricting
these expert surgical procedures to only
qualified
opthalmologists and therefore I will not
440 VY thank you madam chair I would
support on uh two assumptions one is
that the ru making will happen at least
we have set that in motion and also the
fact
that if this is not you know it'll take
a year or more for the rule making
There's an opportunity next term to put
another concise Bill to put more guard
rails so at
least get the ball
rolling so the collaborative effort can
continue so with that in mind I would
support the Bill thank you I'll be
supporting the bill and I'll tell you I
want to go over three things that I
think are important number one our HHS
colleagues did not come to the
subcomittee meeting and that disappoints
me because they should have been here
and they didn't come
because we had a robust conversation
which which you know they could have
helped with but they did
not number
two as the healthcare landscape the
changing there's going to be more and
more of this happening where one
profession versus another profession
there's going to be an overlap of those
professions we see it with nursing we
see it with physician assistance we see
it throughout the healthc care
landscape this is part of
that and that has to happen because
there is a sweet spot within healthc
care where someone is between 40 and 70
right you're not chronically ill but
you're getting older but that group of
people is
growing and that group of people has to
be has to be given that health care
whether or not it's for whatever reason
whether it's less expensive to go to a
mid to a lower to a midlevel
provider there's many reasons
Financial access is also access that's
number three number two number three I
really talk about myself but I spend 40
years in business as a
salesperson I can read a
room and I can read
people and and I am very good at
negotiating and I can tell you that the
lack of negotiation negotiation takes
two
people two groups and really I'm
disappointed in the negotiations that
went on between the two of you I am very
disappointed in that and I hope that
within now and the next couple of weeks
the two of you start talking and two of
you I'm calling you groups I'm looking
at individual people but I'm not this is
not an individual thing it is important
and if you choose not to not to
negotiate or talk it's on you not on us
that's not what we do we do what we're
doing now this is what we do we set up
Frameworks for people to get to work and
if you can't figure that out and it
can't be done in Ru making and it
doesn't happen it won't
happen but what we're saying is this is
important so please
take that into consideration thank
you
Simon thank you madam chair
um listening to the debate during the
amendment session and just kind of
gauging where people were at and trying
to figure out how to address uh the
committee on on my thoughts on this bill
um I've spent a lot of time talking with
people on both sides of the issue and
trying to get to the bottom of of where
things are at I think uh and speaking
privately with a lot of opthamologists
and a lot of
optometrists um I've kind of come to a
few few
conclusions one is that the title that
somebody holds in and of itself does not
make one one qualified to do something
or not do something the title itself is
connected to the level of training
expertise experience that somebody has
accumulated and that level of training
expertise um and experience is directed
towards a scope of practice
um so in the case of an opthalmologist
an opthalmologist has a scope of
practice that far exceeds that of an
optometrist and so their education far
exceeds that of an
optometrist um they do residency they do
Fellowship um which allow them to expand
on what it is that they want to
practice now uh I've had this
conversation with both sides uh when it
comes to a fellowship was which is a
specialty that an opthalmologist would
go into um to my knowledge and nobody
from the opthalmologist side has said
otherwise in my conversations with them
nobody goes into a fellowship for these
procedures um they don't specialize in
these procedures they specialize in
other kinds of procedures that are much
more complicated and complex um first
off because I think it probably requires
that to do it well secondly I'm sure
money probably plays a role because
we're human and that's just the way that
that works that that would be motivating
factor for me um residency yes they go
through medical residency and it's very
involved and it gives them a scope of
practice far beyond the particular
procedures that we're looking at um and
so they're there for three or four years
but that obviously in and of itself is
not required for these specific
procedures because the time spent goes
well beyond these procedures so we're
not making a comparison
between what the opthamologists do for
education and these particular
procedures and whether or not
optometrists can do the same thing in
order to practice the these procedures
what I was trying to do the entire time
was drill down and find out what
education and experience is actually
required to do these particular
procedures and I I will say to my
disappointment I never got an answer to
that from the people who were able to
provide it I was never able to get to
the end to the bottom of that now I
would like to just because I followed
the same train of thought as
representative goalie uh we are in
agreement on this point uh and I had a
conversation with the gentleman from
Kentucky and grilled him on it uh and he
was uh actually pretty upset with the
answer that he gave during committee
that day I said yes it looked terrible
um when he said uh well no there is no
minimum but the answer that he followed
up with was a good answer um and the
answer to that question is there is no
minimum because I believe according to
representative Smith brought this up um
there isn't a one- siiz fits all as far
as how many procedures are done and
whether or not a person is qualified or
proficient in order to do the procedure
right so you can throw five on there and
five can be a minimum but that's not
going to tell you whether or not
somebody is proficient and therefore it
cannot be the last step in the process
of determining whether or not somebody
is qualified in order to do one of these
procedures so for somebody it might be
five for somebody might be 10 for
somebody it might be 20 so the second
part of the of the process that's that's
absolutely essential is to yes get those
Min minimum procedures in but then put
that person under somebody who is
qualified who has been trained and can
oversee the procedures to make sure that
that person reaches a point of
proficiency before released to practice
on their own without that supervision
that will be required in this
legislation um that is completely
essential to represent a Mana P's Point
what I thought was was very very
important this is going to be a slow
moving process we're no optometrist is
going to be able to do this for over a
year well over a year um we're going to
have to go through rules and then
whatever is put into place those new
requirements are going to have to be met
so once again um to a comment that was
made earlier uh yes no school at this
particular point in time U provide all
of the training uh for this scope of
practice um and also uh my understanding
is um that none of the states that have
legalized it allow uh optometrist to
practice it simply based on what they
got out of their schools even if they
went to one of the couple of schools
that trained this way they also have had
um obligations put in place that require
them to work under somebody and have
somebody sign off on their proficiency
no nobody nobody in the state of New
Hampshire will not be an exception to
that nobody allows an optometrist to do
this without going beyond the scope of
just the education at the college level
Nobody Does that everybody recognizes
you're not 100% ready to do these they
have been given a a foundation they've
been given a framework and yes
additional study is required beyond that
in order for them to be able to practice
and do these procedures but somewhere
perhaps in the middle between an
optometrist and an OP olist is a
different space for which we don't at
the moment have a title we don't call it
something because it doesn't exist you
either stop where an optometrist stop
stops or you continue on to where an OP
Opthomologist continues on to but that
does not mean that there isn't a space
in the Middle where we add educational
requirements where we mandate that
they I don't know what it will be
another year worth of training whatever
it is in order to be able to do these
kind of from what I've been able to
gather and somebody can clarify
afterwards if necessary these
intermediate procedures they are not at
the far end of the of the scope of um
comp complexity um and they are not at
the lower level of an optometrist
they're somewhere in the middle and can
people get trained for that middle
ground and what would we call them I
don't know maybe they're optometrist
with some sort of um additional
credential tacked onto it you know that
can be hashed out um but I don't think I
finished my thought which is simply this
I'll be watching rule making this is
important and that's when the and that's
when the people who know that part get
involved as has been mentioned twice at
this table already I believe we're doing
what we do and I do think that actually
what we do in the process has been done
well uh I think that we've set this up
well for success I think we've set this
up well as far as what we can do for
safety uh in accordance with what we do
across the boards um that this is what
we do if we feel or the opthalmologists
feel or whoever can can bring it to our
attention that whatever rules are being
put in place the optometrist lie to us
and they are trying to skirt under the
uh the radar and you know do hack jobs
of uh surgery on people and we look at
the rules and like hey wait there is no
way possible that that is going to meet
the
criteria anybody can bring me a repeal
bill and I will put it in and we will
got the right to do that but the fact of
the matter is and I'll finish up with
this Madam chair cuz talked a long time
but if this were to go to interim study
we would get no further
information we would not be able to
proceed forward any further than we do
the only way I've asked I really have
I've asked and I haven't gotten the
information that I believe the members
of this committee are looking for and
yes it may have only been in this
committee for a week but this has been
going on all year long this information
should have been readily available for
us to just ask and get direct answers to
those questions right away and and I've
asked and I did not receive and what I
did receive is in this amendment I was
perfectly happy to play ball and and I
didn't receive that by by pushing it on
at least to Ru making and allowing the
professionals to Hash it out on the
technical level to see whether or not
this is going to work that information
will come out it will have to come out
it has to come out and once it's out we
have the opportunity to react to that
first through JL car and if not through
JL car by bringing back legislation next
year nobody wants to unqualified
professionals practicing in the state of
New Hampshire nobody wants to put
individuals at risk and um and in order
to figure that out Madam chair I think
we need to push this bill forward and
get that additional information en roll
so I thank you for the committee's um
patience with me as I laid all that out
but I spent a lot of time talking to
people representative goalie thank you
madam chair and I'll be
brief we've heard a couple of times now
since we've had this amendment before us
looking at these two
groups asking them to continue to
negotiate and come back with something
ready Madam chair that came from you and
it came from the ranking member on my
side of the
aisle so I don't understand why we
are going forward with this knowing that
there's something else out there that
could be made to make this bill
better with these Within These two
groups I've chaired many
subcommittees in this house in my 24
years
here and the purpose of a subcommittee
is to get the best product with the
groups together not everybody wins not
everybody
loses getting a compromise between the
and if we have people sitting here at
this table looking and telling you folks
out then the work hasn't been done
completely and for me to vote on
something that with work not done and
saying we have time to figure this out
in rules I I don't agree with and I I
can't support this I've been around long
enough me and representative Schmidt had
this conversation last night on
subcommittee work and I think one toour
subcommittee on a bill this complex
isn't enough with the short and I know
we have a short time frame and it was
what we had to work with but I think it
could use a little more work and I would
hope we would do that thank
you okay that's that's your opinion
representative
Schmidt so with
the very strong vote that we just had on
the amendment that that definitely
strengthen the bill and I commend
representative leut as I said before on
the work he's put in and this amendment
has definitely strengthened the bill and
it's also made it less bad in some
respects um same difference but um the
one thing I think we should not do is
have a unanimous a otpa vote because
uh the house the house is going to go
along uh with an unanimous vote and I
don't think it I think representative
Schmidt we're it's not going to be
unanimous at least two people have
clearly stated they are not going to
vote for the bill and I'm going to be
one of them thank you that makes it
four
okay and I will say that the I I am
don't know that there is anything that
could be added I'm simply saying the
governor has asked if there is something
that could be
added um to your comment I'm not sure
there is something but I will also
mention that when they CA when it came
to the public hearing the
opthalmologists were all saying we get
seven years of residency we're surgeons
we know what we're doing and they were
not dealing with
the specifics of the procedures that the
optometrist wanted to do they were
simply saying a hard no and I think that
if we pass this bill and start into rul
making we will get the optomologist to
actually look at what the requirements
are in order to do these procedures
safely and
effectively and I would imagine they do
not require 7 years of
residency but that's my opinion we'll
find out
anybody
else okay in that case the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment on Senate
Bill 440 and the clerk and call the RO
represent Simon yes represent lakus yes
represent Bailey yes represent saso yes
representative Dolan no representative
Melvin yes clerk votes yes
representative of Boyd
no representative Brown yes excuse me
repres repr gr yes representative
Schmidt no representative goalie no
representative Shu
no representative Malloy yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative
gold representative
Smith representative man
py and the chair
yes four one two three
14 y um 6
nay all right this will not be going on
consent um representative goalie or
someone else does someone else wish to
write what's that representative Shu
will write our Minority Report um under
what motion your motion representative
shuid will be interm
study
okay all
right that we have
right Mr Greenland do you have an
estimate from OS I want that Amendment
we'll be
ready what's
that all right in that case we will
25 to finish with our last
bill what's
that
yes it's uh I don't
2:30 the mo the motion that passed was
ought to pass with Amendment The
study
e
so we are resuming
our
consideration not not till we finish the
work all right so this
is
um this amendment is to add
the
um this is this bill this is to add
amendment 1855 to Senate Bill
here somebody's
car was riding she was riding
okay she left her th of
drink and then I out to my car bring it
back she came over to my car and I
landed it to her and got back in that
car
and
yes why don't you move the amendment rep
for I'll move Amendment um for
representative Gould I will move
Amendment 1855 H all right is there a
second
okay all right and this is the same as
House Bill
1252 but in an appropriate
Amendment
and all right so we're here to debate
that and I certainly hope representative
Bailey and representative ghou will show
I see okay so I I could speak to my
Amendment if you would speak to your
Amendment okay so I am this amendment is
um a duplicate
of House Bill 1252 which this committee
voted and the house voted on and we are
adding it to the um descendant Bill
373 because the Senate chose not to pass
um house bill
1252 which talks about a committee to
study the needs of Native Americans in
New
Hampshire okay represent laus do you
wish to speak your second um I think
that's it I mean we we debated this back
when
1252 um yeah that's that's it does that
and then uh has the committee take a
look at what's going on with the
okay repres man py uh procedural
question um Madam chair so now this
doesn't have to go back to Senate
correct oh it will go back to the Senate
so if and they will be asked if they
want to concur with the amendment or not
they may choose to concur they may
choose not to Concur and kill the whole
bill or they may Concur and ask non-c
Concur and ask for committee of
conference okay so they ask for
committee of conference will agree okay
thank
you okay represent Simon thank you madam
chair in the spirit of trying to give
representative g a couple seconds left
to get back here um I can't support the
amendment not because I'm opposed to the
amendment I just don't see a path
forward for it and if we send this over
to the Senate side
um I I just don't think that they're
going to accept that they were pretty
staunchly against it in the first place
and I don't really want to have the
underly Bill affected um by it or just
really more likely adding another step
to the process to arrive at the same
conclusion so um so for that reason uh
as much as it breaks my heart to not
support representative gold I I will not
be supporting the
amendment all right any representative
Schmidt well I'm glad to hear
it I'm I'm glad to hear that because I
think there's that they'll request a
committee conference uh they'll come in
our position will be the whole bill with
the 1252 their their their counter will
be drop it or the the whole thing goes
down um and so I totally agree with the
chair's remarks um and I would just
counsel my colleagues uh to uh respect
the testimony that we heard from um
members of the Commission in before the
Senate I was there and I heard them say
it uh that this B this the the committee
is is actually viewed by the commission
as uh as
a as as a salt in the gasoline sugar in
the gas whatever you want to call it
antithetical in other words I should
have stuck with a big words for the
first place uh antithetical to the
commission that we already have that is
functional if the they can get a a Forum
back which is what the other bill that
we
had had as an objective so uh in
addition to the chair's very precient
remark about no path forward it's it
it's it's not a good idea in spite of
the fact that it passed the committee
but as I
said 40 people were in the listening
audience if you will and weighed in 38
to2 against this bill against this text
of this amendment
so it's not really in the interest of
the Native American commission thank
questions Brown thank you I I don't have
my big binder with that original bill in
it there can anyone enlighten me on what
the concern there was some concern that
there was inaccurate information passed
around at the original hearing and I
when we voted for this and I can't
remember that if anyone I'm not asking
you to say anyone it is inaccurate sorry
about that but um if anyone can
Enlighten my memory
on why we decided to move ahead with
this how's that representative G you you
have an answer you said I I do um the
concern had to do with
this oh no
okay I'm incorrect what I thought was
here is not in this bill so I take it
back
sorry well part part of it I think was
the the idea of of State recognition and
what that implied because we aren't
really sure what it does imply but it's
different than Federal
recognition thank you y represent laus
yeah I believe on the state I mean
there's repr G's back maybe she can
answer better but my understanding is
there are some uh federal law that will
apply if there's State recognition so
having the state recognition would
affect that the other thing is um you
know I take um represent Smith's
comments about the commission
but there's also I think some reason to
believe believe that the commission had
some functionality issues Beyond Quorum
and so um you know I think part of the
idea was to see if there might be some
changes the commission either membership
or their charge that might have um
allowed it to work better and so I'm not
surprised they were opposed but I don't
positive okay representative uh G and
then M py thank you madam chair my
apologies Glennon I took the best route
the quickest we could to get here um
okay I'm going to speak a little more
openly than I've spoken in the past I've
worked really hard to be uh cooperative
and um try to get through this process
in the most productive way possible the
reality is that as I stated earlier we
were told that we had a representative
of the commission working with us but
then there was a change and the rest of
the commission wouldn't honor what the
Comm Mission member had agreed
with there are many factors they're
complicated but one factor I can tell
you is that and it is a fact that a
couple of years ago all of the
recognized native all the Native
Americans enrolled in recognized tribes
both federal and state recognized tribes
quit the commission at the same time in
in a week's time and that's been a big
part of what led to the loss of seats
and as we all know the governor's office
is very very slow to um to make those
appointments to refill those
seats of course I was blamed for those
seats not getting filled which of course
I had nothing to do with and I would
only advocate for those seats to be
filled I've advocated for the commission
with representative Dolan's committee
again I was blamed that that I was
trying to kill it uh it's you know we
cannot understand what the opposition is
because we're not getting uh forthright
honest answers we're not getting
cooperation I reached out to the
commission when I did the first bill on
recognition and they were working with
me until there was a a thing they wanted
and I was trying to talk to them openly
and honestly about why that would be a
problem and they just quit talking to me
so it's this lack of
communication even when you try that's
part of the the problems and uh the
study committee is to give some
legitimacy and Credence to the path to
recognition and there are many reasons
as has been said here why State
recognition matters other people are
entitled to hold a different opinion
that it doesn't matter but it does
matter and a quick example I'll give you
is that 603 diversity just came out with
a article totally dedicated or largely
dedicated to the abanaki there's many
articles in it one of them is my husband
making his birch bark canoes under the
birch bark article but there's another
one written by the chair of the
commission who is the one who opposed
this bill where she talks
about the abanaki and she talks about
the Vermont tribe
and then she talks about three groups in
New Hampshire who are not
recognized so this is what we've been
battling is that those of us who live in
New Hampshire who were not given a path
to
become legal
Indians under the federal law by
enrolling in a recognized tribe as soon
as Vermont recognized a tribe in order
for any of us to sell our arts and
crafts we would be illegal and so the
only path to follow federal law was to
enroll in a tribe and since that
happened in 2011 we're now characterized
as foreigners in our own state so these
issues are complicated they can be very
painful for some people they can be very
threatening to some people who may not
have the history and background to meet
criteria but they then again they may
the criteria and we won't know until we
study it I think that's about all I want
to say on it okay repres
man I don't know if I can follow the
suit with what you said my understanding
was that the representation on the
commission from all tribes was not equal
or it was not
represented and so
that's that was just my simplistic mind
understanding that unless all tribes are
uh on at the table at on this commission
it's really not a fruitful thing to do
that that was my understanding I could
be totally wrong but that was where I'm
going anyone
else yes thank you madam chair for
allowing me to follow up there is one
other piece I'll say and um my esteemed
colleague to my left said to me on the
way in uh just now we I really don't
know enough
about Native Affairs to really
understand the issues and I said yes
that's the problem and my husband is
just astounded that the response to we
don't know enough about it has been so
we're going to kill studying it that it
just is incongruent that the way we're
going to learn about it is to work with
the commission as a study committee gets
formed invites the commission to come to
the table everybody starts to hear open
and honest communication
happening then an understanding can grow
from
that represent Brown thank you madam
chair if if this were to go to Committee
of
conference would we whoever that is
would we abandon this piece so that we
didn't lose 373 I know you don't know I
can't predict the future I don't know it
would depend on what the Senate wanted
and how strongly they wanted it and how
strongly we want the other part
okay could go either
way okay any one
else all right the motion is to adopt
Amendment
1855 to Senate Bill
373 and the clerk can call the RO
represent Simon regretfully no represent
lakas yes representative Bailey
no representative
Brown representative groa yes represent
Schmidt
no represent goalie oh he's not here
sorry representative Shu
yes representative Davis
no representative
gold
yes representative Smith yes represent
Manti
yes and the
chair
six yeah N9 y 6 nay sorry okay the
motion
passes
motion so um representative gold yes I'd
like to move uh the bill House Bill
373 is it yes
uh amend with with the amendment to P
ought to pass
second
okay do you wish to speak to your
motion o I think I've said everything I
need to say um the underlying you know
the original bill as I said before I
think is really important as well and I
really appreciated the Chairman's
explanation that in the committee of
conference um there's wiggle room either
way but preserving air change is
important to me as well represent leas
you wish to speak to your M uh nothing
to add
else all right well
I'm concerned about losing the content
of the bill but we'll see
okay the motion is octop pass with
Amendment on Senate Bill
373 and the court can call the role
representative Simon
yes representative lak
yes represent Bailey yes representative
Dolan CL
vote Yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown representative
gold
yes representative Smith yes
representative manuti
chair reluctantly
yes 13 Y 2
nay all right the motion passes
13-2 I object to consent so we won't put
it on
consent um representative Schmidt are
you or Davis will either of you be
report
okay Davis are you no okay well um fine
um committee reports are
needed we'll take them tonight
representative Schmidt you14 302
representative Simon
485 I have representative Golds on
488 and Le representative leases on
600 and
318 uh and 440 was 4 coming okay so
representative Gould you owe an also ow
373 thank you madam chair if you like
I'll send you what I had written for the
ought to pass that would be lovely okay
that's
that and thank you that is our
uh as far as I know this is our last
Committee Action until the fall anyone
that is has
responsibility for one of the interim
study bills will be expected to write
the report on it and hopefully do the
study uh if you want to volunteer for
for any of the those study committees
please talk to the person who's the
leader on that and it's posted in the
office anybody else have
anything thank you madam chair I just
want to say thank you for including me
in this being part of this committee
this is my last uh time I'm not running
again so I kind of feel good about being
on this for just a year but very
enlightening and very inclusive Comm um
committee and I thank you for running of
great committee and subcommittee and I
felt very part of it and I appreciate
apprciate that okay represent blackis um
as I think people know I'm not running
again also um my name was on the interim
study for House Bill 1333 which is
Banning EVs and state fleets they're
going to need somebody else to take it
over because I'm either going to be out
of town or out of the country for um
much of the time the study would be done
and certainly for the uh meeting in the
fall okay anyone want to volunteer for
studying
EVS what is the hello what's the
schedule for doing interim studies you
can since we have completed our
committee work you
can you can start now July is off
usually most of August is off there's a
yeah represent gold thank you madam
chair I was just going to say that I
have um two that I got named for one is
Atlantic time and the other is uh what's
left of merging boards surveyors and
scientists and all some other stuff um I
would be happy to take on the EV if
somebody else would take on one of those
other two
bills study committees well to be honest
we've decided that the Atlantic time
doesn't need anything anymore because
so you want to co-chair Carol if let me
know what anyone decides we don't need
to know
today all right uh yes I would yes I
will do that with yous or uh the Eves
okay we'll change the
name yeah the mic's are having an issue
here okay well he's does that all right
you we'll see what
happens what what what the voters decide
that's always the issue all right thank